Pog, Pog, Pog, Poggers.
Moment.
Postman, Französischer, Pogger, Smiley.
Smiley sagt man ja heute Emote, Emote.
Da ist er.
So, mal gucken bis Switch gecheckt hat dass da Stream on ist.
Aber mit progress gemacht Leute harter progress
MonkaS progress
Huge progress ich sags euch
Jetzt gehts ab am ende sind wir fertig
Wollen wir mal kurz ein update von meiner Linux Kiste
Weil ich hab das Gefühl ich hab das schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht
Ach du Scheiße
Seht ihr erstmal das halbe Internet runter oder was ist denn hier los
Das ist doch kein NPM
Guck mal hier
Hä was
Was will er
Ich weiß nicht
Yes einfach immer Yes sagen
Erinnert mich an den China-Mann wo wir früher im Essen gegangen sind in Frankfurt
Was ist China-Mann
Stimmt ja gar nicht
China-Restaurant das waren eigentlich glaube ich alles Mädels
Die da bedient haben und in der Küche keine Ahnung
Wahrscheinlich ein Koch oder so
Die haben auch immer gesagt
Einfach Ja sagen bei der Bestellung
Wir sind da hingegangen und haben überlegt was wir bestellen sollen
Und da war die Antwort von der Bedienung sagen einfach Ja
Okay
Was sag ich jetzt Ja
Weiß man nicht so genau
Es war Poggers China-Laden in Frankfurt
Mal gucken
Mal gucken ob es das noch gibt
Aber ich empfehle nicht dahin zu gehen
Ich sag nur
Das war früher richtig geiler Chinese-Laden in
In Frankfurt weil es war billig und viel
Nicht der Magic-Wog
Der Magic-Wog ist das auf der anderen Seite glaube
Ja
Doch doch das ist das
Das ist das hier der Magic-Wog
Und da haben wir früher bestellt
Und als die Bedienung da war und ich hab die Bedienung nie verstanden
Weil ne die ist halt sehr chinesisch die Bedienung
Und dann irgendwann meinte die Bedienung zu mir einfach sagen Ja
Und seitdem bestellen wir dann nur noch mit Ja
Ja das war der Laden hier in Frankfurt
Jetzt kann ich das in der Website haben
Facebook Alter
Wer ist denn auf Facebook
Wer ist heute noch auf Facebook Leute mal ernsthaft
Ist einer von euch noch auf Facebook
Ja gut ich bin noch auf Facebook
Ich hab halt meine Facebook-Seite aber ich bin da ja nicht mehr
Ich mein guck mal
Ich hab die Seite halt einfach ich hab die nicht gelöscht das ist alles
Also ich war da nicht mal eingeloggt seit 5 Jahren oder so
Ja ok seit 3 Jahren
Seit 3,5 Jahren war ich da nicht mal eingeloggt
So useless Facebook
Richtig Boomer-Book Facebook
Nur mein Geburtstag Leute ist euch eigentlich aufgefallen es gibt neue Sub-Batches
Seht ihr das
Wir haben jetzt Sub-Batches 2 also also Sub
Das kann sein das sich das noch ändert
Das kann sein das sich das noch ändert also es gibt
Ein Monat Subscriber ist
Hatte ich nicht irgendwo ein Bild gepost
Hatte ich nicht ein Bild gepost
Ja also ein Monat Subscriber
Guck mal Twitter Alter Twitter ist so ein Shit Alter
Schaut euch das mal an
Also ein Monat Subscriber ist der Holzkeks
2 Monate ist ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es so bleibt ich hab ja noch viel mehr als die
So danach kommt der normale
Dann ab 3 Monate gibt es den Silberkeks
Den gibt es für 3,4,5 Monate gibt es den Silberkeks
Ab 6 Monaten gibt es glaube ich den Diamantkeks
Und ab glaube ich einem Jahr gibt es den Keks mit der Goldhalskette
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob ich das so eingestellt aber ich hab noch viel mehr
Das ist jetzt erstmal zum testen also es kann sein das es nicht so bleibt
Ok 3 Monate ist Silber, Silberkeks
2 Monate gibt es noch den normalen
Wenn einer 1 Monat hat das müsste eigentlich der Holzkeks sein
Ja im letzten Video hab ich den mal eingeblendet
Wir müssen jetzt mal warten bis irgendjemand kommt der vielleicht schon über
einem Jahr dabei ist der müsste dann eigentlich ein
Ne warte mal ab 3 Monate also wenn
Ok 5 Monate
Warum kriegst ah ich glaube ab 6 Monaten ist der
Diamantkeks 10 Monate
Auwe Lei du müsstest den Diamantkeks haben
Versuch es mal aus schreib mal was in den Chat
Du müsstest den Diamantkeks haben
Aber danke für den Sub du hast den Diamantkeks
Poggers
Kunst
So und falls jetzt noch irgendeiner mit 12 Monaten plus da ist
Der müsste den Goldkeks haben
Müssen wir mal ausprobieren
Hey Max wie kann man bei Ubuntu ein Laufwerk bei jedem Start automatisch mountain
Na FStub ist die Oldschool Variante
Dazu brauchst du aber Route Rechte
Gut zu mountain brauchst du eh Route Rechte
Es sei denn es sei denn es ist ein
Wie heißt das
Gvfs Mount oder so
Über Gnome für USB Geräte
Dann geht das glaube ich auch usertechnisch
Da müsste ich mir was überlegen
Das ist das schöne am i3 da kann ich beim
Beim Einloggen einfach in Skip laufen lassen
Hexner Teil 3 ich hoffe ich krieg
Das am Wochenende gebacken und Beta
Ich werde es auf jeden Fall spielen auf jeden Fall Videos zu
Machen aber ob ich stream wahrscheinlich
Stream ich auch zumindest mal ein bisschen wir müssen wir müssen aber
Zur Vorbereitung darf da davor noch ein bisschen
Battlefield 3 spielen
Wir müssen ein bisschen Battlefield 3 üben davor
Wann ist eigentlich jetzt die
Ist das jetzt offiziell
Achter oder so oder
Am achten war das am achten
Hier
Ah ja hier am achten
Und am sechsten
Hä
Ah gut
Moin Leute
Cloud VMs sind Remote Code Execution
As a Service
Also wenn man nur diese
Wörter nimmt ja dann ist das so
Aber das ist ja meistens was anderes gemeint
Dass da irgendwo was Executed wird was du nicht willst das
Executed wird
Mal gucken ob das Update gelaufen ist
Hat jemand von euch der vielleicht arbeitet einer von euch in dem Bereich
Problemen mit Let's Encrypt
Gabs
Hat jemand irgendwelche Schmerzen
Klasse
Smalles Update
Also bei uns ging es
Ja das stimmt
Hattet ihr Probleme mit
Also Fadda
Hattet ihr Probleme mit euren Server Zertifikaten
Oder mit kleinen Verbindungen
Eigentlich sollte es ja nur an kleinen Verbindungen diesmal gelegen haben
Denke mal
So
Ich mach erstmal Update
Du
Mit Exchange
Exchange
Kleine Verbindung heute gestern mit iPhones
Mit alten iPhones wahrscheinlich oder
Die sind ja ab iOS 10 ist es ja kaputt
Also unter iOS 10 ist es ja kaputt
Am iOS 10 in 5er oder so wahrscheinlich
Also alles was irgendwie so 2016
2016 17 ausgelaufen ist
Echt mit 15ern
Die sollten der Sache eigentlich trusten
Sind AWS Zertifikate
Auch Let's Encrypt
Also wenn kostenlosen vielleicht
Weiß ich nicht
Aber
Ich weiß nicht
Also wenn AWS automatisch generiert für Domains
Dann kann ich mir vorstellen dass es Let's Encrypt ist aber ich weiß es nicht
Hab ich noch nie ausprobieren
Rust Compiler
Warum zum Teufel compilert da irgendwas gerade
Was ist denn Pipes RS überhaupt
Pipes
Dafür warte ich jetzt 5 Minuten
Auf mein Update bis er das kompiliert hat
Das ist wichtig da müssen wir warten jetzt
Ich bin noob aber was wurde bei Let's Encrypt gemacht
Gar nichts also nicht in Form von
Dass du was machen musst
Das alte Route Zertifikat
Von Let's Encrypt ist ausgelaufen
Das Route Zertifikat
Was die mal ursprünglich verwendet haben
Die haben ja 2, die haben ein neues das geht bis 2035
Und wahrscheinlich ist es auch das wo es dann mit weiter geht
Und die hatten noch ein altes mit dem sie damals gestartet sind
DST Route X3 hat das im Namen
Und das ist ausgelaufen gestern um 16.01
Und das ist normalerweise nicht schlimm
Die Zertifikate die du hast die gehen weiter
Aber Kleinverbindungen die dem neuen
Route Zertifikat nicht vertrauen
Der Postman ist out of date
Ja dann müssen wir Postwoman verwenden
Ist das nicht so
Gab es denn nicht auch ein Package
Weil irgendjemand gesagt hat Postman ist zu sexistisch
Gibt es dann nicht auch Postwoman mittlerweile als Package
Ich bilde mir ein habe ich irgendwie sowas gelesen
Post
Oder vielleicht bringe ich das durcheinander
Da war einer wieder besonders korrekt
Warum ist das out of date
Weil man weiß es nicht
Na ja gut
Reboot
In your face
Stimmt Cloudflare kannst du auch ganz gut jetzt Zertifikat
Aber es gibt halt Sachen da kannst du
Oder willst du nicht Cloudflare davor haben
Also wenn es kein HTTPS ist
Ist es mit Cloudflare davor eh erst mal vorbei
Und sicherlich kannst du irgendwelche paid options nehmen oder so
Und
Manche willst du vielleicht aber kein Cloudflare davor haben
Ja
Wir hatten auch lustigerweise ein bisschen Stress
Aber auch nur weil es die Leute wieder so spät gecheckt haben
Was auch bei uns bei uns war wirklich
Wieder Triple Keg W angesagt
Keg Quadruple U war auf der Arbeit angesagt
Wir haben eine Abteilung die kümmert sich
Abteilung ist zu viel gesagt stimmt nicht
So 2, 3, 4 Leute
Die kümmern sich um das Ausstellen von Zertifikaten bei uns
Normalerweise eigentlich nur um das Ausstellen von Zertifikaten
Einmal wenn du Internet Zertifikate brauchst
Und wenn du irgendwelche kostenpflichtigen Zertifikate brauchst
Dann holen die das und die sind permanent am Schießen
Gegen Let's Encrypt
Die sagen jedes mal Leute kommt zu uns
Lasst eure Zertifikate kaufen
Wir empfehlen auf gar keinen Fall Let's Encrypt zu verwenden
Sag schnell was zu
Und
Diese Let's Encrypt Sachen haben die wieder genutzt
Komplett umlegend Let's Encrypt zu schießen
Was aber witzig ist die hatten genau das gleiche Problem als letztens mal
Irgendwie einer ihrer CAs die sie verwendet haben ist schon eine Weile her
Die ihr Root Secret verloren hat
Und außerdem hätten die genau
Das gleiche Problem gehabt jedes Root Zertifikat
Läuft irgendwann mal aus
Sag mal ist heute irgendwas auf Twitter oder so
Auf Twitch
Hab ich heute irgendwas übersehen
Na gut heute ist Freitag Abend heute ist Freitag Abend
Weil es sind erstaunlich wenige auf Twitch
Kein grafisches Login ne
Hier ist er
Alle in New World
Weiß nicht ich weiß nicht
Ich glaub das ist ich glaub nicht
Ich glaub nicht New World ne ne
Backt bei mir ein bisschen rum
Weil normalerweise haben wir eigentlich saumäßig schnell
150 200 plus Leute
Nicht das mich großartig stören wird
Aber ich frag mich immer was da los ist
Was hier regen sie sich auf
Ich hab Fortnite gelesen Leute
Fortinet
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was ich schlimmer finden soll
Na ja was auch immer da ist
Fortnite benutzt auch Let's Encrypt arme Kiddies
Ey mich würdest du nicht wundern ganz ehrlich ich würde auch nur Let's Encrypt verwenden
So hat er jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet
Ich würde auch nur Let's Encrypt verwenden wenn ich ein Game rausbringe
Also wenn ich irgendwelche HTP Arpies bräuchte
Warum sollte ich irgendwas anderes nehmen als Let's Encrypt
Ich verstehe es eh nicht
Bei uns auf der Arbeit gibt es auch so 2-3 Leute
In diesem Zertifikatsteam die permanent erzählen
Wir weisen darauf hin wir haben keine freien Zertifikate
Gefährlich ist freie Zertifikate
Gefährlicher
Gut weil man sie dafür dann nicht mehr braucht wahrscheinlich
Aber das ist doch Schwachsinn
Let's Encrypt Zertifikaten wird getrusted wie jeder anderen CA auch
Das macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied
Und das richtige CAS also was heißt richtige CAS also so paid
Paid highly professional CAS
Dass die genauso gut Scheiße bauen und auch mehr Scheiße bauen hat man ja gesehen
Was war das Komodo oder so
Aber du würdest Let's Encrypt spenden wenn du im großen Stil Zertifikate brauchst
Also wenn ich Fortnite wäre
Und im großen Stil Let's Encrypt verwenden würde ja dann würde ich dir was spenden
Sollte der Preischamp irgendwann mal voll durch die Decke gehen
Nicht damit Milliarden machen dann spende ich auch was
Wobei das ist glaube ich moment der Preischamp ist
Ist glaube ich gar nicht Let's Encrypt der ist glaube ich Cloudflare null
Nee Cloudflare spende ich nicht kann ich gleich
An Amazon spenden oder so
Landet auf dem Konto von irgendeinem der eh schon viel zu viel Geld hat
Am besten nur Shell ohne Gui
Ja da fehlt die Maus keine Discord Notifikation
Ah deswegen dauert es ein bisschen
So erstmal hier IDE was ist das
Monkeys warum
Warum ist das hell auf einmal
Was ist das
Mit der letzten Version war das noch Dark Seam warum ist das jetzt kein Dark Seam mehr
Warum ist das jetzt
Game Seam
Hier
Downgrade habe ich das nicht installiert
Downgrade
Erstmal downcrate und gucken ob irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist
Downcrate
Ja ja
From Cache 161
Proceed
LUL
Warum ist die neue Version das Seam kaputt
Was ist denn das schon wieder für ein Shit
Da kriege ich immer Anfälle wenn sie so unsinnliche Änderungen machen
Ok
So mal
Nicht broken
Broken
Default Seam Loading
Da ist was
In older versions sind Default Seam almost almost loaded
Based on some unclear rules also für mich waren die Rules nicht unclear
Das wurde jedes Mal geladen
Das hat mir ehrlich gesagt gereicht
Das muss klarer sein das hat jedes Mal das Default Dark Seam geladen
Das war mir vollkommen ausreichend
Sometimes some random patch code was loaded and sometimes
Good
Whatever
Was muss ich denn jetzt überhaupt machen
Was Default Seam
So below CSS completely removes
Default Seam and loads
Default Seam
De69
Stefan
Decyp
Carbon
Go
Und da ist der Heiz-Champ. Ich muss die Home Assistant vor allem mal anmachen.
Und wir hätten schon viel weiter sein können. Hätte ich nicht so viel geschwätzt die letzten zwei Streams.
Ich habe fast nichts gemacht. Ich glaube den letzten Stream habe ich es geschafft drei Zeilen Jason zu basteln oder so. Guck mal.
Ich glaube den letzten Stream, das einzige was ich geschafft habe ist das hier.
Das ist alles. Ich habe zu viel geschwätzt. Das war nichts. Das hier und am Ende irgendwie das Thermostat setzen.
So also Home Assistant, Configure, Unable. Wow, warum?
Ah, V-Monker. V-Monker ist nicht gestartet wahrscheinlich. Ah ja okay die V-Monker ist nicht gestartet.
Dann warten wir kurz bis die V-Monker gestartet ist. Dann können wir auch auf den Home Assistant drauf.
So jetzt sollte es eigentlich funktionieren. Nee immer noch nicht.
Was gibt es denn? 2.133 ist doch alles richtig. Alles richtig.
Was ist das eigentlich für Spooky Spoda Musik?
Home Assistant in der V-M? Ja zum testen. Was ist denn hier schon wieder los jetzt? Anzeige ist...
Ah, Hoggers. Ja hier ist unser Thermostat. Da haben wir aufgehört. Ich pushe noch mal kurz.
Die aktuelle... Das muss ich wieder exporten. Das ist ja.NET 6. Wir haben ja gerne mal das mit.NET 6.
So Heizung. Hat nicht funktioniert. Warum nicht?
Ah jetzt. Okay man muss doppelt pushen. Okay also prinzipiell funktioniert das Pushen von Informationen an Home Assistant.
Aber das müssen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen schöner machen und vor allem funktional, weil aktuell ist das Ganze hardcoded.
So übrigens Leute mein Hals ist wieder viel besser. War doch kein Corona.
Zumal ich bin ja eh doppelt geimpft und hab Test gemacht. Also die Corona hatte wenig Chancen.
Aber mein Hals ist wieder deutlich besser als die letzten Wochen. Also zeigt mal hier.
Ich muss mal Twitch fragen. Kein Schimmer. Ich bin jetzt quasi geimpft, genesen. Was ist das dritte G?
Getestet. Ich bin geimpft, genesen und getestet dann quasi. Aber ich bin ja gar nicht wirklich genesen, weil das war gar kein Corona.
GGG das sind die Entwickler von Passive Exile. Grinding Gear Games. Also welche Programmiersprachen kannst du?
Lass mal überlegen. Moment. Da haben wir doch mal eine. Ach du Scheiße das weiß ich nicht mehr wo wir das gemacht haben.
Wir haben doch mal eine Liste gemacht. Ich hab doch extra für solche Fragen mal eine Liste gemacht. Was heißt mal?
Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Weil solche Fragen öfters kommen. Mal eine Liste gemacht.
Was ist das denn für abartiges T++ Zeug? Ah das war Battlefield. Skill. Irgendwas mit Skill hieß das.
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr.
Okay keine Ahnung. Vielleicht haben wir das hier gemacht. Lienungsbewertung? Nein das war was anderes.
Ah da haben wir es doch. Da haben wir es doch. Ich wusste es doch.
Also ja weil wir haben wir. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr wozu. Irgendwann habe ich mir das mal aufgeschrieben was wir für Dinge gemacht haben. Also Programmiersprachen.
Was kann ich dann? Zeigt mal her. Das war eher ein Gag. Moment das ist Markdown. Das können wir sogar rendern lassen.
Was gibt es denn da schönes? Stack, Stack, Stack Edit. Das wollte ich. Stimmt ich wollte es für meinen Chef machen diese Liste.
Weil ich mit ihm mal besprochen habe dass ich ihm sowas gebe. Damit ich noch mehr anderes Zeug machen kann. Aber habe ich glaube ich die gemacht.
Können wir das mal rendern lassen? Hier guck mal hier. Powergas gerendert. Jetzt haben wir sogar richtige Five Head Progress Bars dahinter.
Also ich kann an Programmiersprachen. Also ich kann kein Kobold. Das ist ein Witz. Ich kann wahrscheinlich Kobold besser als 99% der Weltbevölkerung.
Das ist nicht gelogen. Aber es kann auch niemand. Es kann wirklich keine Sau Kobold und geschweige denn gut. Also ich kann in Kobolds Files einlesen.
Konsolenausgaben machen. Was ist das hier für ein Knopf? Konsolenausgaben machen und was weiß ich Elemente in Erase anhängen oder sowas.
Das war es. Das ist vorbei. Mehr kann ich nicht. Also jetzt kommen wir mal zu den ernsthaften Programmiersprachen die ich wirklich ganz gut kann.
Also C-Sharp kann ich würde ich sagen richtig gut. Das ist meine mit Abstand auch Lieblingsprogrammiersprache. Ruby kann ich auch ziemlich gut.
Ruby ist eigentlich neben C-Sharp meine zweite Lieblingsprogrammiersprache. Aber leider ist Ruby ein bisschen abgefallen die letzten Jahre über.
Dank dem Niedergang von Rails. Also ich weiß ich ursprünglich fand ich Ruby und Rails mal ganz cool. Aber mit der Zeit ging es mir auf den Sack.
Also ich mochte Ruby und Rails eigentlich nicht so wirklich. Und deswegen ich würde gern Ruby verwenden. Aber nachdem Ruby und Rails jetzt ziemlich niedergegangen ist,
verwendet man kaum noch Ruby und da Python so übelst abgegangen ist durch die Decke die letzten paar Jahre über durch irgendwelche Blockchain-Dinger, AI, DevOps-Geschichten ist Ruby halt nicht mehr angesagt.
Aber Ruby kann ich auch ziemlich gut. So Meinung zu Django. Hab ich nichts mit gemacht bisher. Ich weiß nur was cool an Django ist, dass sie so eine Management-Web-Interface standardmäßig eingebaut haben.
Sagen zumindest alles, was ganz geil ist. Bash. Wiedererwartend kann ich Bash auch ziemlich gut. Das liegt daran, weil ich fast, ich kann es gar nicht in die Jahre sagen, aber einige Jahre war ich Serveratmen und hab ganz viel Bash Zeug gemacht.
Also Bash kann ich ziemlich gut. Python kann ich auch ganz gut. Also was heißt. Wirklich können ist jetzt, ich kann es ohne Probleme lesen. Ich verstehe was passiert. Ich kann es auch schreiben. Ich hab doch einige Sachen drin gemacht.
Aber ich bin jetzt nicht der Profi. Also ich würde mir jetzt nicht zutrauen, irgendwelche AI-geschützten Bild-Auswertungs-Dinger so ohne großartig zu programmieren oder sowas.
Auch CC++. Ich hasse es. Also C ist nice, aber es gibt kaum was, was ich mehr hasse als C++. Aber ich krieg's ganz gut hin, sofern man C++ gut hin kriegen kann. Das hat man auch bei den ganzen ESP-Streams gesehen, wo wir sogar ein bisschen Low-Level-Assembler-Zeug gemacht haben.
Also ich kann das eigentlich ganz gut, aber ich hasse es. Es gibt kaum was, was ich wirklich in der gesamten IT so sehr hasse wie C++. Es ist schrecklich einfach nur. Java kann ich lesen, da hab ich noch nie großartig was mit gemacht.
Groovy ist die einzige Sprache, wo ich bisher jemals etwas größeres drauf gemacht habe auf JVM-Basis. Go kann ich eigentlich ganz gut. PHP hab ich auch schon ein bisschen was mit gemacht, aber schon eine Weile her.
Ich bin übelster Noob, was SQL von Handschreiben angeht. Ich krieg so die Basics hin. Ich kann irgendwas selecten, inserten, joinen. Beim Join wird's schon schwierig. Den Join hin zu wurschteln, der funktioniert.
Ja Rust hab ich auch schon mal gemacht. Weiter haben wir glaube ich nicht gemacht. Ich glaube hier haben wir aufgehört. Ja, hab ich glaube ich ausreichend beantwortet.
Desktop, das ist besser. Sagt was und ich finde es. Easy. Sagt mir irgendwas und ich finde es instant. Challenge. Pet GIF, da ist es. Hier. Siehst du es? Da. Easy.
Browser MP4, da ist es. Easy. Lull Econ, da ist es. Ah ne, ist Lull W. Naja, ich finde es auch nur so schnell, weil man was tippen kann auf dem Desktop und es dann findet.
Paar Sachen weiß ich. Hier sind die Projektideen, hier sind die Streamideen. Hier ist irgendwie Aufwachen, Videos, was auch immer. Kannst ja frag einen Milliardär gucken auf YouTube. Das haben wir uns schon längst angeguckt. Das ist outdated, overrated.
Was ist denn das? Ist das irgendwas Monkartossisches? Warum hab ich ein EAS Pack auf dem Desktop? Was ist das? Darf ich das zeigen?
Das ist das, was wir uns damals für Battlefield zugeschickt haben, oder? Keine Ahnung, das darf man zeigen. Das ist nichts Neues, das ist schon eine Weile raus. Also nicht das Game, sondern die Infos.
Stimmt, ich kann direkt einen VS Code previewen. Ich bin richtig dumm. Ja klar kann man das. Ich bin richtig eng geblieben, natürlich.
Kann man direkt hier previewen. Bin echt total bescheuert, weiß gar nicht, warum ich das gesucht hab. Ich mach das normalerweise immer zu 90% so. Es sei denn, was witzig ist, bei uns auf der Arbeit, bei einer Sache buggt die Markdown Vorschau im Visual Studio Code, wenn ich nämlich ein Markdown Dokument aus unserem Git Repo nehme.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwas mit Bitbucket zu tun hat, was aber eigentlich merkwürdig ist, weil Bitbucket ist ja nur oben drüber. Das Repo selbst hat ja eigentlich damit nichts zu tun.
Dann stimmen die Umlaute nicht, da ist irgendwas encodingmäßig kaputt. Alles andere geht.
Du hast deine IHK Abschlussprüfung geschrieben. Achso, 1995. Ja gut, 1995 hat man aber schon gesagt, Cobol ist eigentlich outdated, geh ich mal von aus. Aber Cobol lebt immer noch.
Es gibt Sachen, die sterben einfach nicht. Ja, wir benutzen Bitbucket. Ich bin zwar nicht happy drüber, aber wir benutzen Bitbucket.
Meinst du, dass Cobol alles übernehmen wird? Nö, warum soll es? Keine Programmiersprache wird je alles übernehmen.
Vielleicht gibt es irgendwann eine Programmiersprache, die alles abdeckt, aber Cobol ist immer noch da.
Ist Bash eine richtige Programmiersprache? Klar. Wird das nicht eher so wie HTML gezählt? Nö, Quatsch.
Bash kannst du alles machen, was eine Programmiersprache aussieht. Du hast Schleifen, du hast Ifs, du hast sogar 50 verschiedene Schleifen, je nachdem, wie du das machst.
Du hast sogar Arrays, Bash Arrays und Tags. Das ist, glaube ich, das hässlichste, was es so gibt. Guckt euch das mal an, Bash Arrays und Tags.
What the hell? Guckt euch das mal an. Bash Arrays und Tags. Ja.
Nee, Bash hat alles, was eine Programmiersprache ausmacht. HTML hat keine Bedingungen, hat keine Schleifen und sonst was. Höchstens mit irgendeinem Template, mit einer Template Engine. Aber... Ach so, TypeScript.
Siehst du, wir waren damit noch gar nicht fertig. TypeScript kann ich da auch hinschreiben. Zumindest ungefähr so gut wie JavaScript.
Also, Bash ist eine vollständige Programmiersprache. Nur keine sonderlich schnelle.
Was auch witzig war, es hat einer bei uns auf der Arbeit Squid-Proxy-Log-Auswertungen programmiert. Sie wollten irgendwie zählen, wie oft im Monat was aufgerufen wird oder sowas und nach speziellen Kriterien.
Das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich hab geguckt auf GitHub und hab einen Log-Auswärter gefunden für Squid, der das macht. Aber irgendwie unser Log-Format ist natürlich so krass custom, dass er nicht funktioniert, hat der Log-Auswärter.
Geil, oder? Wir haben es wieder irgendwie geschafft, das ist was super zu customisieren. Zumindest hat nicht funktioniert.
Also, was hab ich gemacht? Ich hab ein.NET-Programm gemacht. Irgendwie 20, 30 Zeilen, gar nicht so viel. Und hab Multithreaded die ganzen Dateien eingelesen, sortiert und gemerged am Ende.
Und zack! Sein Script, das Bash-Script von ihm, das lief, glaub ich, eine Woche in Produktion. Mit dem Live-Proxy. Eine Woche, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen. Eine Woche.
Und was meint ihr, wie lang mein.NET-Programm gebraucht hat? Erschätz mal, also, Bash, Bash braucht sieben Tage. Man muss denken, das war eine 48-Core-Kiste.
Eine 48-Kerne-Kiste. Wie lang hat man die Sharp.NET-Core-Programm gebraucht? Nee, nee, nee, nee. Nee, so schnell war es auch nicht.
15 Minuten ist schon ziemlich gut. 15 Minuten ist schon ziemlich gut. Ich glaube, es hat irgendwas zwischen 15 und 20 Minuten gebraucht.
Da hat er geguckt.
Nee, C++ ist... Moment. Wo hab ich denn mein MonkaS? Das hab ich ja schon lange.
Das ist C++.
Was hat Microsoft bei C Sharp eigentlich anders gemacht? Haben die einfach nur die Kack-Ideen von C++ gefixt? Nee. Also, da muss ich... Also, da kann ich jetzt einen Roman drüber erzählen.
Aber wir wollen heute Progress machen, Leute. Bam! Progress hab ich gesagt. Aber da sag ich trotzdem was. Da sag ich trotzdem kurz was zu.
Also, was hat Microsoft richtig gemacht bei C Sharp? Erstens, sie haben keinen Verrückten aus dem C++ Gremium genommen, um da irgendwie mitzuwirken, sondern haben sich mit Anders Heilsberg jemand genommen, der weiß, wie man ordentlich Programmiersprachen macht.
Also übrigens der gleiche, der danach auch TypeScript gemacht hat. Sie haben sich im Prinzip an Java orientiert mit bisschen C++. Nur, dass die so ziemlich alles Dumme rausgelassen haben von C++.
Und die Sachen viel konsequenter und sinnvoller umgesetzt haben und, und, dass sie einen Zukunftsplan hatten für die Sprache.
Also, die haben es permanent geupdatet, neue Sachen eingebaut und die Sprache permanent aktuell gehalten. Das ist das, was Microsoft richtig gut an C Sharp macht jetzt, auch wenn Anders Heilsberg nicht mal dabei ist.
Die sind immer dabei, die Sprache zu updaten und immer aktuell zu halten. Also sprich, selbst wenn es neue coole Errungenschaften gibt in dieser Richtung.
Aktuell, die letzten paar Jahre hat sich ja durchgesetzt, dass Programmiersprachen immer, immer mehr quasi so in die funktionale Ecke gehen.
Also heutzutage ist es zum Beispiel vollkommen normal, dass man in der Programmiersprache hier sowas schreiben kann. Hier, guck mal zum Beispiel. Keine Ahnung.
Äh, äh, Liste. Oh, U. U, List, Int. So. Oh, nice. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. Ist vollkommen egal. Irgendwas. So.
Und dass ich dann sagen kann, Liste und zum Beispiel, äh, Wear. Das geht im, äh, in JavaScript heißt es Filter und in noch anderen Sprachen heißt es Frass vor sich.
Dass du sagen kannst, ähm, ich will jetzt nur alle Elementen, Elemente, die größer als 5 sind. Und dann kriege ich, äh, Liste 2 raus, dann kriege ich eine zweite Liste raus, die nur alle Elemente enthält, die größer als 5 sind.
So. Das hier ist eigentlich was, was man so aus funktionalen Programmiersprachen kennt. Aber das haben die schon vor Urzeiten in C Sharp eingebaut.
Und die machen sowas, die machen sowas permanent. Also das ist, das ist das, was, was Microsoft richtig gut macht.
Patrick, danke schon für den Sub. Kann's Maus machen? Du, ah ne, du bist Moderator. Ich dachte, da müsstest, aber du müsstest jetzt eigentlich, müsstest nur den Goldkeks haben. Nicht, nicht weil du Moderator bist, sondern weil über ein Jahr. Meinung zu Objectives-T kann ich nicht sagen. Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, Go, Go ist tatsächlich relativ easy, aber ich mag nicht, äh, es gibt Sachen an Go, die ich echt nicht mag. Aber insgesamt ist Go absolut, äh, ja, zu gebrauchen, ja.
Wir müssen übrigens demnächst das Hardware-Rad-Tool fixen, falls ich da noch einer dran erinnern kann. Das geht nicht mit Windows 11. Weiß ich, ich erinnere mich hier immer noch an das Hardware-Rad-Tool. Wir haben mal so ein Tool gebaut, wo Hardware-Rad seine Windows-PCs mit aktivieren kann, weil dieses 0815 Zeug nicht funktioniert hat.
Das besteht aus einem Web-Interface, wo man Windows-CD-Keys hinterlegt und einem Agent, der sich per Broadcast aus dem gleichen Netz einen Key abruft, ähm, als used markiert und äh, den Installations-Aktivierungs-Agent durchklickt.
Und da funktioniert mir Windows 11 nicht mehr. Das müssen wir demnächst wahrscheinlich fixen. Nein, das ist nicht Windows XP. Windows XP ist übrigens nicht betroffen, gewissen von der Let's Encrypt-Geschichte. So was habe ich nicht auf dem Desktop.
Ja, und es funktioniert. Warum hast du Quicktime für Sony Vegas? Es heißt ja nicht mal mehr Sony Vegas. Weiß gar nicht, wem der Kram jetzt gehört.
Magix. Nee, kenn ich nicht. Kann ja jemand Sockel programmieren. Ähm, je nachdem, was du machen willst. Ist das nicht so schwierig?
Was willst du denn machen? Oh guck mal, das ist hartnäckig, ist er. Ja, das ist Schwachsinn. Das sehe ich genauso. Die meisten Programmiersprachen haben ihre Daseinsberechtigung.
Sogar C++, so schwer es mir fällt, das zuzugeben. Auch wenn es mega sackt. Also, nee, eigentlich hat C++ gar keine Daseinsberechtigung. Die ist einfach nur historisch an den Stellen, wo sie jetzt ist und deswegen gibt es da leider nicht so viele Alternativen zu in manchen Bereichen.
Aber ansonsten ist das eigentlich die erste Sprache, die ich... Wenn ich irgendwas cancelen dürfte, ist ja gerade angesagt, dass Dinge gecancelt werden. Ich würde C++ cancelen.
Also ich bin extrem vogue, was Programmiersprachen angeht und ich cancel C++. Das muss weg. Ich auch nicht. PHP ist gar nicht schlecht.
Wenn man das mit so was wie Laravel oder so was verwendet, verstehe ich auch nicht so genau, warum die Leute so scheiße finden. Ich glaube, das ist historisch bedingt. Wie gesagt, PHP, finde ich, ist besser als sein Ruf.
Ich dachte, man kann es wenigstens einstellen, hier, dass da Kickstarter angezeigt wird. Das ist ja schon fail. Da fängt man an zu GameDev zu... Was? Da fängt man an zu GameDev zu streamfinden auf der Page einfach den Max.
Ja, siehst du mal. Schön, dass du da bist. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das ausspricht. Itami GameDev? Poggers. Vor 8 Jahren hatte ich ein Video. Es ist ein super geiler Konfett. Schönen Kuss. Leicht, dass du da bist. C++ hat keine Daseinsberechtigung. C++ ist nur Alternat... Ja, leider. So ist es echt.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Es gibt in vielen Bereichen keine Alternative zu C++, weil es sich einfach nichts bisher großartig in dieser Richtung etabliert hat. Man könnte durchaus sagen, Rust, das Problem ist, dass vieles gerade was Embedded-Sachen angeht, programmiert man in ESP32 zum Beispiel, oder programmiert man das Zeug, was der Patrick da programmiert. Ich weiß gar nicht, was der programmiert, aber es ist so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da für die passenden Tools gibt, ob das überhaupt möglich ist, das mit Rust zu programmieren. ESP kannst du auch nicht mit Rust programmieren. Da gibt es zwar Anfänge, aber es ist nicht fertig. Nee, ich hätte auch absolut keinen Bock drauf. Rust ist der Abfakt pur, wenn man schnell was machen kann.
Aber für sicherheitsrelevante Sachen, oder auch gerade für Microcontroller-Zeug, stelle ich es mir eigentlich relativ cool vor, wenn es ordentlichen Rust-Support gäbe. Ich glaube, vieles bei Rust-Support gibt es nicht. Es gibt nur ein paar.
Aber für sicherheitsrelevante Sachen, oder auch gerade für Microcontroller-Zeug, stelle ich es mir eigentlich relativ cool vor, wenn es ordentlichen Rust-Support gäbe. Es gibt nur ein paar.
Du meinst, im Jahr 2021 ist das kein Problem, oder? Ein simples Socket-Kommunikationsprogramm war es einfach, und es ging zum Sorgen wieder zurück.
Ja, also ich müsste mal nachgucken. So ein Socket kann ja durchaus auch ein bisschen betriebssystemabhängig sein, wenn man es ganz low-level machen will, aber in C-Sharp mit der Standard-Lib ist das nicht sonderlich schwer.
Du machst ein Socket auf, du musst glaube ich sagen, du willst ein TCP-Socket haben zum Beispiel, und dann kriegst du irgendwie eine Network-Stream und kannst daraus lesen und schreiben. Das ist nicht so schwierig.
Ich müsste aber selbst erst mal nachgucken, wie das funktioniert. Aus dem Kopf wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht alles auswendig, aber es ist nicht so schwer.
So, aber jetzt noch mal Progress, Leute. Was hältst du von Java als Web-Backend? Ist gut, kann man verwenden, klar. Man kann fast alles als Web-Backend verwenden.
Es ist ja eigentlich egal, in was dein Web-Backend programmiert ist. Eigentlich ist es egal. Solange du damit das machen kannst, was du machen willst, ist es egal. Du kannst auch im Brainfuck... Wobei gibt es... Moment.
Im Brainfuck hattet ihr Web-Server? Och du Scheiße, sowas geht es wirklich, oder? Warum ist das? Warum gibt es das? Warum gibt es einen Brainfuck Web-Server?
Ah, yes. Obviosly, was das macht. Die sind noch nicht mal ganz dicht.
So Leute, jetzt wird Progress gemacht. Jetzt wird Progress gemacht.
So, jetzt wird Progress gemacht, Leute. Jetzt geht es ab.
Also, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Zeigt mal her. Also, wir haben es geschafft, ein Thermostat zu rendern in Home Assistant. So, was ich jetzt ausprobieren wollte...
So, ich wollte eine andere Optik erstmal für das Thermostat ausprobieren, nämlich das hier.
Hat jemand letztens im Chat geschickt? Weil ich habe letztens im Chat noch gesagt, ach hier, das reicht doch. Aber ganz ehrlich, dieses Thermostat ist mega kacke zu bedienen auf dem Tablet mit diesem Slider. Ich weiß auch nicht, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben.
Deswegen probieren wir jetzt mal das andere Thermostat aus. Die andere Thermostat Plugin. Oder was ist Plugin? Andere Thermostat GUI für Home Assistant.
Das ist eine gute Frage sowie eine schlechte Frage. Wenn ich damit anfange, mache ich bis 21 Uhr nichts anderes mehr, als mich über 10++ aufzuregen. Das ist eine äußerst gefährliche Frage hier zu stellen.
Aber wenn du es wirklich wissen willst, kann ich das gerne, entweder nachdem ich heute vielleicht ein paar sinnvolles auf die Reihe gekriegt habe, dass ich nicht erfrieren muss wegen meiner Heizung oder vielleicht einem der nächsten Streams erzählen. Dann erzähle ich dir das ruhig nochmal, ja?
Danke schön für den Sub. Vorgast.
So, also probieren wir das doch mal aus. Wie bindet man das ein? Ich glaube, ich brauche jetzt mal Hacks. Hex? Brauche ich Hex? Alter, Hex. Massive Hex. Nein, Dismiss. Ich will mein Shield Tablet, äh, nicht Shield, Shield TV nicht discoveren.
Also, wie installiert man den Kram nochmal? Es gibt für Home Assistant, das ist eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee. Wieso ist Home Assistant ein Image?
Hä? Was? Jetzt das blick ich jetzt nicht. Ein Image? Das verstehe ich wirklich nicht. Nein. Meinst du, warum ich das in der VM habe oder?
Stimmt ja, cute. Der Nightbot ist procken. Kann das sein? Nee, Nightbot geht.
Na gut. Also, ähm, in Home Assistant haben sie das eigentlich ganz clever gemacht. Die haben recht viele Standardelemente dabei, um Sensoren und Sachen anzuzeigen.
Ja, zum Beispiel haben die Thermostat Komponente, eine Sensor Komponente. Ja, wenn ich sage, hier Sensors, da kann ich ja auswählen, was ich für einen Sensor haben will.
Ich habe jetzt hier keinen großartigen, ja, und dann kann ich den anzeigen lassen. Alles ist gut. Aber, wenn man, äh, was will, was abseits der Standard-Optik ist, dann gibt es kein, standardmäßig kein Pluginsystem fürs Frontend oder kein, doch, es gibt ein Pluginsystem fürs Frontend, aber keinen, ähm, einfachen Weg, neue, äh, GUI-Elemente nach zu installieren.
Deswegen haben sich Leute von der Home Assistant-Community gesagt, sie machen so eine Art App-Store oder Community-GUI-Store für Home Assistant. Ist eine ganz praktische Geschichte. Das Ganze nenne ich Hex.
So, jetzt müssen wir das mal einbinden. Das habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht, weil meine Home Assistant einfach funktioniert. Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal, wie es funktioniert.
What? Ein Jithub-Account brauche ich. Warum brauche ich ein Jithub-Account? Vielleicht machen wir das jetzt doch nicht. Ich habe zwar ein Jithub-Account, aber nichts dafür.
Okay, kann man das vielleicht manuell installieren? Manual install. Hier. Natürlich kann man es manuell installieren. Also, download simple thermostat.js from latest. From latest. Download ich das. From latest.
From latest. Hier. Da. Bam. Da ist es. Copy link. Okay. Wohin soll ich das downloaden? Nach configuration www. Also, ssh 122.168.123. Das ist die, ich glaube 222 läuft das.
Das ist die Adresse, wo mein Home Assistant zum Testen drauf läuft. Ah, Leute, ich bin ja auch doof. Ich habe kein SSH-Addon drauf installiert. Ja, kein Wunder.
Installieren wir das mal. Wirst du dir Windows 11 direkt downloaden und muss ich bei einer neuen Windows Version ein Backup machen? Ich habe gehört, dass Windows 11 nur wie ein Update sein soll, dass man nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das laufen wird.
Ich werde mir aber auch Windows 11 nicht direkt downloaden. Ich werde mir das holen ab dem ersten Patch, wenn es das gibt. Ja, das ist ganz einfach.
Hat hier wer Erfahrung mit dem Host und Internet-Anwender auf dem Raspberry Pi? Hat mir einen geholt? Irgendwo. Nee, das ist total einfach. Du musst das noch nicht mal auf dem Raspberry Pi entwickeln. Du kannst das auf deinem Desktop entwickeln und sagst dann einfach.net publish und sagst dann als Target Linux ARM.
Das ist total einfach. Guck mal, das haben wir glaube ich sogar hier. Linux ARM. Das musst du machen..net publish minus c release, dass er eben alle Optimierungen macht beim Kompilieren, minus r Linux ARM self-contained.
So und wenn du das machst in deinem Projekt, dann kriegst du die Anwendung komplett in einem Ordner und den Ordner kopierst du rüber. Du könntest übrigens auch noch publish, single, file oder irgendwie so wie das heißt machen. Dann kriegst du einen komplett executable File dafür. So ist das ein Ordner.
Und diesen Ordner nimmst du, kopierst ihn auf den Raspberry Pi, startest ihn und es funktioniert. Du musst einfach gar nichts machen. Aber Achtung, Raspberry Pi Zero geht nicht. Nur die normalen. Ab dem 3er. Also 3er und 4er geht 2er glaube ich auch nicht. Du kannst kein Raspberry Pi Zero verwenden.
Zero müsstest du mono verwenden, geht auch. Aber.net Core kann kein Zero, weil das ARM. Was ist das Zero? ARMv7, ARMv8 ist das neue, ARMv6 oder? ARMv6? Ist das Zero? Ach was weiß ich.
So jetzt ist SSH add-on installiert. Configuration. Username. Passwort 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Huge save Passwort. 2, 2, 2. Achso ich kann es Port 22 machen, weil es exklusiv da drauf läuft. Exquisite, exquisite. So starten. Bam. Start. Lock. Auf geht's. Was?
Something is wrong. Warum?
Ich weiß, dass mein Passwort unsicher ist. Das juckt mich aber nicht.
Was ist mir doch egal, ob mein Passwort unsicher ist? Okay. Underscore, das ist bestimmt auch da drinnen. Wollen wir mal gucken. Restart add-on.
Fuck man. Okay, ich brauche ein neues Passwort. Ich weiß, was nicht drin ist. Cute chat 1, 2, 3 ist nicht drin. Restart add-on. Aha. Schon funktioniert's. Guck. Easy. Easy. Yes. Cute chat 1, 2, 3. Was? Eine ist nicht Max. Das ist Hass.
Add. Cute chat 1, 2, 3. Jawoll, da sind wir. CD. Config. CD. WWW. Gibt's nicht. MK dir muss man. WWW. WWW. Und jetzt weget diesen Krempel da.
So, habe ich gemacht. So ein Stück. Und was muss ich weitermachen?
Manual. Download simple format in your configuration. WWW. Folder. Das ist doch, da bin ich doch hier richtig, oder?
Ja. Previously you could download the source file from here.
Configure Loveless to load card. Ob das jetzt funktioniert, da bin ich mal gespannt. Rufen wir das doch mal auf und gucken, ob das funktioniert. Local, simple, not found. Aha.
Funktioniert schon mal nicht. Lul. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Excellent, excellent. Wollt eigentlich nur ein scheuneres Thermostat haben.
Wie hat man jetzt zusätzliche Ressourcen noch mal hinzugefügt? Frontend? Nee. Loveless dashboards. Ressources, genau. Add resource.
Module create. Wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Welche Distro benutzt du? Ich benutze Manjaro mit E3WM. So, hat er das jetzt installiert?
Loading Module was blocked. Disallowed mime type text plane. Was ist denn das schon wieder für ein Kack? Warum funktioniert die Anleitung nicht?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Jo, keine Ahnung. Ich hab doch alles gemacht, was da steht. Home, assistant, www, folder. Where is config www? Tja, das freut mich auch.
Tja, anscheinend, anscheinend bin ich zu pepega dafür, zu erkennen, wie man das macht. Das ist anscheinend zu advanced für mich, sowas zu installieren.
Ich dachte, ich mache hier einen www-Folder und dann ist gut, aber nope. Ich würde das jetzt gerne ausprobieren.
Jo. Nee, nee, das ist schon hier richtig. Das ist hier richtig. Ziemlich sicher, dass das hier richtig ist.
Das ist richtig. Ich weiß aber nicht, warum ich das nicht sehe. Was war es? Bam, Reboot. Achso, Reboot jetzt einfach. Vielleicht geht es dann. Reboot, Reboot, Reboot. Hilfbar sowas. Ha, Reboot. Nee, wie geht das? Ha, Reboot. Restart.
Nee, ich will das OS restarten. Host. Host. Reboot. Bam. Ich kenne dich noch als MaxFPS mit Battlefield Videos. Ja, ja gut, mich gibt es ja auch auf YouTube immer noch.
Ich heiße hier auf... Moment, Moment, Moment. Was? Äh, nope. Das ist der Solution, Alter. Warum zeigt es erstmal den Friseur an und danach den Solution und dann den Danny, Alter?
Achso, achso. Okay, ich wusste gar nicht, dass ich aussehe wie der Friseur, aber alles klar. Ich bin ja immer noch, ich bin ja immer noch auf YouTuber. Ich habe sogar gestern erst ein neues Video hochgeladen. Ich zeige euch mal vor.
Woop League. Max, kiffst du eigentlich? Dicker Weed ist bald legal. Skur Skur. Vape Nation. Alles klar.
So, ist es wieder da? Hat es jetzt restarted? Nee, er hängt noch.
So, wir gucken jetzt aufs Funktionierte. Wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann programmieren wir weiter und lassen diesen GUI Mist weg.
Es ist wieder da, es ist wieder da. Home Assistant ist Home Assistant auch wieder da. Ach guck mal, jetzt kann er es laden. Jetzt geht das. Lul, was ein Shit, es kann doch nicht sein, dass man das neu starten muss dafür, dass es das lädt.
Okay, Hide everything but sensors and temperature control. Also das brauchen wir jetzt. Type, custom. Okay, okay. Wie heißt meine Klimaanlage? Nicht Klimaanlage, wie heißt meine Heizung hier drin nochmal?
Fügt es nochmal ein, dass es auf jeden Fall drin ist. Wie heißt mein Element hier nochmal? Climate Heizung. Okay, das kann ich mir gut merken, da weiß man gleich was Sache ist. Okay, probieren wir das mal aus.
So, Bäm. Climate Heizung. Safe. Okay, funktioniert. Ja, es ist halt ein bisschen kompakter, ne? Wie schaltet man jetzt den State um? Wie schaltet man jetzt den State um?
Wie kriege ich das hier so hin? Wie kriege ich das hier so hin? Ach ne, das ist der Compact Mode. Moment, das ist der Compact Mode. Ich habe explizit den Compact Mode eingeschaltet. Aber den Compact Mode.
Ah, man kann sogar Hilfetexte. Ach guck mal, der hat sogar einen GUI dafür jetzt. Das ist ja cool. Aber es reflechst nicht dynamisch.
Äh. True. True. Lulve. Ah, so sieht das aus. Okay. Machst du auf? Ja, klar. Ich habe schon zum neuen Battlefield ein paar Sachen zum besten gegeben auf YouTube.
Sogar schon vor letztes Jahr Weihnachten. Als es noch gar nicht raus war, was es ist. Und jetzt auch erst wieder vor kurzem. Ich habe sogar mit dem Lost zusammen letztens was aufgenommen.
Ja, das werde ich auf jeden Fall spielen und auch auf jeden Fall ein paar Videos zu bringen. Wie viel, weiß ich noch nicht. Kommt darauf an, wie sehr mich das Game packt. Ja.
Okay, Frage an den Chat. Welches Thermostat ist besser? Dester oder Dester? Bevor ihr also was sagt, denkt daran Tablet Bedienung. Denkt an Tablet und Smartphone Bedienung.
Okay, wir machen mal eine Abstimmung. Aus den Links, Bedienung rechts sehe ich genauso. Weil wir machen mal eine Abstimmung. Was ist schicker? Wir customisern das linke, das rechte dann auch gleich noch. Man kann das ja wohl ein bisschen customisern.
Was ist schicker? Links, rechts? Umfrage.
Ich hätte gerne Pfeile oben und unten. Ja, wenn die hier ohne Scheiß hätten die hier neben, meine genug Platz ist ja, würden die hier daneben noch Pfeile machen. Dann wäre das optimal. Dann könnte ich nämlich hier scrollen und nicht scrollen.
Dingsen hier, wie auch immer man das nennt. Sliden und hätte noch hier Pfeil. Das wäre natürlich ganz cool. Aber das kann das nicht.
Gut, das ist halt für ease of use gemacht. Du kannst halt hier nichts einstellen. Aber hier ist es schon wirklich cool. Du kannst ausschalten, kannst anschalten, kannst plus minus schalten. Wirklich, wirklich ganz schlecht.
Die meisten Leute sind der Meinung, rechts ist schicker. Ich würde fast sagen, links sieht optisch vielleicht ein Ticken besser aus. Links mag vielleicht ein Ticken besser aussehen, aber rechts ist die funktionalere Variante.
Interessant. Links ist edler, genau. Aber rechts ist besser, um Tablet zu bedienen. Jedenfalls. So was kann man da sonst noch schönes umstellen.
Muss man links nicht immer 20 mal draufdrücken? Nee. Mit dem Tablet musst du links ein paar mal draufdrücken, bis du es erwischst. Ja, das ist das Dumme. Oder du gehst in die Settings und machst es hier.
Das finde ich aber kontraproduktiv, dass du ein Thermostat hast, wo du dann in die Settings musst, dass du es ordentlich bedienen kannst mit dem Tablet. Das ist doof.
Da ist mir das lieber. Übrigens an Ausschalten geht nicht, weil mein Programm nicht läuft.
So, mal gucken, wie man das noch customisieren kann. Haben die ein paar Examples? Examples, sehr schön, Sensors.
Different Example Usage of Sensors Templating Support ist da auch noch drin. Okay, man kann es auch übertreiben für einen Thermostat Sensor. Erstmal eine komplette Programmiersprache einbauen. Easy.
Okay, das müssen die nicht einbauen. Das ist ja schon mit dabei. Das Home Assistant Frontend hat ja dieses Templating Zeug drin.
Mach Normal Mode, nicht den Kompakt Mode. Ich habe auch nicht den Kompakt Mode, oder? Hab ich doch. Kompakt ist, wenn ich das hier alles auf False stelle.
Version 3? Warum soll ich da Version 3 rein? Eins, zwei, drei, vier. Hä? Version 3. Ah, jetzt ist alles klar.
Das schaut aber anders aus. Ja gut, dann mache ich diesen ganzen Mist hier. Ah, guck mal da.
Ach, wahrscheinlich durch das Layout. Das Layout ist das. Das Layout macht es ein bisschen kompakter. Guck mal, dann hat man die Sachen oben und unten. Was findet ihr besser? Plus, Minus oder oben und unten? Hoch, runter oder Plus, Minus?
Also ich muss sagen, ich persönlich finde Hoch, runter besser, aber ich weiß genau, dass meine Mutter, die würde garantiert Plus, Minus intuitiver finden.
Hundertprozentig. Oben und unten. Was kann man da sonst noch so einstellen?
Wisst ihr, bei so Beispieldokumenten wäre es immer sinnvoll, wenn ein Bild dabei wäre.
Was haben die hier eigentlich die ganze Zeit mit Version 3? Version 3. Ah, Version 3 heidet irgendwelche Dinge.
Ach, man kann, wenn ich Version 3 setze, dann kann ich quasi die Optik noch weiter templaten oder wie? Naja, das muss jetzt ja auch nicht wirklich sein.
Ja, da kann ich hier noch mehr. Da kann ich andere Sensoren anzeigen und sowas. Nee, das brauche ich nicht.
Ja, das sieht ja so aus. Ich meine, meine Heizung, da habe ich ja gesagt, hier guck, da habe ich ja gesagt, du kannst nur off sein oder heaten.
Was ja auch sinnvoll ist für eine Heizung. Warum soll ich einen Button für cool machen, wenn meine Heizung eben nur heizen kann, weil es eine Heizung ist.
Sowas kann man sonst noch schönes machen. Header. Ich gebe dir Header, alter. Dicken Header. Okay, macht Ctrl-False.
Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich nur für Compact Mode. Set Points. Set C-Section. Layout. Okay. Step. Aha.
Also kann ich jetzt hier auch sagen Layout. Step Row hatten wir. Was war das andere Column? Ach so, das ist das hier.
Das ist hier Default anscheinend, ja. Mode. Disable. Ah, da kann man jetzt noch Customize noch.
Nee, was war das? Mode Disable Elements. Ach nee, das ist noch eins drunter. Ah. Ja, das finde ich so besser. Wozu? Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Wozu soll da drüber daneben Operation stehen? Das ist eigentlich komplett useless. Ist doch klar. Ausheizen, da brauche ich ja nicht Operations daneben stehen zu haben, oder?
Das ist doch. Icons, Names. Names? Will ich Names ausmachen? Nee, ich glaube Names will ich anlassen. Service.
Must specify both domains. Was? Nee, brauchen wir nicht. Unit. Ah, das ist für alle Kokonas. Das ist für alle Kokonas. Unit.
Das ist wenn ich da nicht gerade, das ist dann, pass mal auf, Kokona Style ist das. Das ist wenn ich sowas hier haben will. Unit. Kokona Style. Ja.
Aber Homosystem ist ordentlich eingestellt. Das benutzt, das benutzt standardmäßig. Was ist denn Kelvin überhaupt? Gibt, gibt sowas? Ich habe das so in dieser Art glaube ich noch nicht gesehen.
23 Kelvin wäre ganz schön kalt. Ja.
Was wäre dann minus 23 Kelvin? Irgendwie was minus 250 Grad oder so, ne? Ungefähr minus 273 oder so ist glaube ich das Maximale.
Und dann wären 23 ja irgendwie sowas 250 minus 250 Grad Celsius. Ja, das wäre schon ziemlich kalt.
Specify numbers of decimals. Oh, das ist natürlich praktisch. Da kann ich den Müll von decimals 1, das ist besser. Oh, das ist viel besser.
Aber die Steps sacken. Leute, die Temperatur geht nur noch hoch, nie wieder runter. Gleich explodiert die Heizung.
Das ist wirklich kaputt. Super, ersten Bug gefunden. Ich kann nicht mehr auf Kälter schalten. Exquisite. Okay, das muss weg.
Wieder Keks gebacken. Genau, das muss weg. Ja, jetzt geht es wieder. Ich glaube ich weiß wo der Bug ist.
Der match bestimmt hier hinten drauf irgendwie, ob er es neu rendern soll. Und das klappt nicht, weil ich einmal klicke und es ist 05er Step anstatt ein ganzer Step.
Und deswegen kommt er damit durcheinander. Ach, hier Stepsize. Guck mal, easy, kann man sogar angeben. Ja, dann ist es ja noch besser.
Stepsize 1, ein bisschen schepp, okay. Und jetzt kann ich bestimmt auch machen Decimals. Fuck nein, geht nicht.
Wie Stepsize? Okay. Moment, Stepsize 2 ist Stepsize 1. Warum ist 2 1 und 1 0,5?
Das ist glaube ich nur für 500 EQ. Decimals 0. Ne, wie war das?
Warum überhaupt? Ah, jetzt geht es. Hä? Was ist dann Stepsize 0,5? Ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt. Stepsize ist mal der Stepsize, die ich hier angegeben habe.
Wobei hier habe ich auch Stepsize. Ach, ich habe hier keine Stepsize angegeben. Okay, standardmäßig ist glaube ich 0,5 und das ist 0,5 mal 2 ist 1.
Das ergibt tatsächlich Sinn in dem Fall. Was aber trotzdem ein bisschen kontraintuitiv ist. Kann Stepsize 0,5 sein?
Ja anscheinend, aber da muss ich mehr Decimals machen. Ne, weil das ist Kokona, das geht bestimmt so. Ach, was auch immer.
Wisst ihr was das dumme ist? Mit zwei Decimalstellen sieht das besser aus. Obwohl ich nur das vordere verstelle.
Also ich finde, wenn ich nur das hier verstelle, aber es hat zwei Nachkommastellen sieht das irgendwie besser aus.
Schwer zu sagen warum, aber ich finde das sieht besser aus. Okay, was haben wir sonst noch? Fallback? Jaja Label brauchen wir nicht.
Height Controls. Reset. Brauche ich nicht. Sensors? Brauche ich nicht.
Header. Name overwriteen. Aber man kann sogar noch einen Switch oben hin machen. Da könnte ich vielleicht noch einen Switch machen für warm Wasser oder so.
Wobei ich will warm Wasser nie abschalten, nie. Wenn ich das hier dann implementiere, was ja an die Heizung schicke, wäre das ganz einfach.
Heat ist warm Wasser plus Heizen und off ist nur warm Wasser. Ganz einfach. Also ich brauche da gar keine großartigen Sperenzchen machen.
Das ist tatsächlich relativ easy. Icefreak, dankeschön, 21 Monate. Probier mal aus, du müsstest jetzt einen Goldkeks haben als Avatar.
Schreib mal was im Chat. Du müsstest einen Goldkeks mit Kette haben, weil du bist über 12 Monate Subscriber. Guck mal hier.
Das ist nicht Pog. Ja, Leko, du hast auch einen. Goldkeks, wo? Nur wenn du Subscribed hast. Ab 12 Monate.
Ab 12 Monate, also es gibt, es gibt aktuell, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es so bleibt, ich habe nämlich noch mehr.
Wenn du startest, bei einem Monat kriegst du den Holzkeks, danach kriegst du den normalen, dann kriegst du bis zu einem halben Jahr Silber.
Ab einem halben Jahr kriegst du einen Diamond und ab einem Jahr kriegst du einen Goldkeks. Und ich werde das aber noch ein bisschen anders abstufen.
Wer ist denn Sabrina? Ah nein, ich klicke keine Trends auf Twitter an. Das ist nicht gut. Da weißt du immer nicht, was dich erwartet.
So, Laubbläser. Diamond ist unter Gold. Ja, Diamond ist unter Gold, weil Gold eine Kette hat und Diamond nicht. Und die Goldkette sieht einfach viel cooler aus.
Aber ich habe noch mehr. Ich habe noch mehr in dieser Richtung. Und ich brauche auch auf jeden Fall was für eineinhalb, zwei Jahre.
Weil da habe ich ja mittlerweile auch schon welche. Ich glaube die meisten, ich glaube 27 Monate oder so haben teilweise manche schon Subscribed.
Weit über zwei Jahre Band-FPS, wenn du das angestellt hast. Ja, das befürchte ich auch.
Flynn, nee Finn und Hiha, danke schön für den Sub. Hier auch Massive Goldkeks. Erstmal Resub. Die Abo-Falle greift, Leute.
Die Abo-Falle hat gegriffen. Guck mal, das Scam-Train ist am Start.
Der Chibay-Train. Könnte direkt an Bezos überweisen jetzt die Kohle. Ja, Finn, schön, dass du am Start bist.
Ist heute irgendwas kaputt gegangen wegen letzten Encrypt? Nee, gestern ist es abgelaufen. Nicht heute, gestern 16 Uhr. Nee, ist nichts kaputt gegangen.
So, okay, genug rumgespielt. Ich würde sagen, das können wir so lassen. Jetzt können wir ein bisschen Proga-Stalls machen.
Das gefällt mir. Doch, das gefällt mir. Also jetzt muss ich wirklich sagen, in dieser Kombination gefällt mir das auch besser als das eingebaute Thermostat.
Ey, warum ist das so verbackt? Warum sind es jetzt zwei auf einmal?
Das weiß auch nicht, was es will, oder? Jetzt ist die Step-Size auf einmal doch.
G-Baited, Mensch. G-Baited. Okay, jetzt geht es trotzdem so. Kann es sein, weil du bei Step-Sizen... Das habe nicht ich gemacht, das hat das Plugin für mich gemacht.
Musik ist ein bisschen MonkaS-mäßig. Okay, so ist gut, so lassen wir das.
Also, jetzt basteln wir mal ein bisschen weiter. Ja, da stand Number, aber wenn du reinklickst und rausklickst, also wenn du da wieder rausklickst, macht das automatisch einen String rein.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum. Ich traue denen einfach, die wissen besser, wie es geht. Okay, jetzt noch mal schnell checken, ob das auch mit dem Senden der Kommandos funktioniert, wenn ich da drinnen rumklicke.
Also, was ist, wenn ich jetzt hier umschalte auf 16, dann... Sollte da jetzt eigentlich 16 stehen? Weil wenn ich hier auf 1629 umschalte, dann steht...
Irgendwie ist es broken.
Gestern ging das noch.
Ach nee, ich habe nur Mode. Ich habe nur Mode-subscribed. Okay, schalten wir um, auf off geht. Schalten wir um, auf on, auf heat geht. Probieren wir es hier aus. Off, heat. Ja, funktioniert.
Funktioniert. Funktioniert. Ich habe nur einen ausschalten. Subscribed. Ich subscribe und auch mal Temperatur. Können wir auch mal ausprobieren.
Thermostat, Mode, CMD. Nee, was? Target, Temp, CMD.
So, und jetzt sollte er beides ausgeben.
Schalten wir hier an, aus, geht immer noch. 15, bam. 20, zack, jawoll.
Excellent.
Sehr nice. Okay, jetzt können wir da was Sinnvolles machen. Also erst mal diesen ganzen Shit hier wieder wegschmeißen.
Ich kommentiere mal aus. Ich glaube, das könnte ich gleich brauchen.
Warum MonkaS? Normalerweise freut sich der Chat immer, wenn ich ein paar Weep-Emotes spamme.
Das ist jetzt das erste Mal, dass da jemand sagt MonkaS, wo ist hier, wo sind die Q-Chat-Vertreter?
Ich wusste es doch.
Das ist einfach, das ist, das ist nur, weil das Ebaro so lange nicht da war.
Weeps in. Me Weep, me spam, what bucka if bam.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Oh, jetzt sind die Nummers da.
So, wisst ihr was? Ich kommentiere das jetzt alles aus. Bam.
Alles weg. Alles, alles weg. So.
Also, was brauchen wir denn? Ich leg jetzt mal, das ist ein Switch.
Ich leg jetzt mal eine extra Klasse für das Thermostat an. So, und die heißt H-A-M-Q-T-T.
Thermostat oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Okay, zack. Richtig, clean code. Clean coders hassen diesen Trick.
Okay, sehr schön. Also, wir machen das jetzt mal ein bisschen ordentlicher.
Was ist denn das? Hab ich irgendwas doppelt? Ja, tatsächlich.
Okay, also wir legen den Thermostat an. Wir machen das jetzt mal ordentlich.
Wir legen den Thermostat an. Neues Thermostat.
So, das Thermostat kriegt einen M-Q-T-T-Client im Konstruktor und kriegt einen,
ach so, so rum, einen Name. Ja, den Namen, den haben wir ja schon. Der Name ist Heizung.
So, ich lösche das, ich lösche das alte, by the way, ich lösche das alte jetzt mal.
Weil, sonst erkenne ich ja nicht, ob es funktioniert.
So, device, zack. Der Heiz-Champ wird gelöscht, bam, delete. Grip-Heiz-Champ.
Name, Heizung, wo ist das Problem?
Doch, richtig. String, Name. Ah, Root-Device brauche ich noch, okay.
Device in Form. Das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Was ist denn das? Ist ihm wirklich seine Wand gegen den Kopf gefallen?
Das sieht ja aus, null. Bam. Ziemlich wackelig angelegen, Heide.
Das ist ultra bekannt, ich kann das nicht. Ach, ist das der Tür? Oh, aber der hat Glück.
Da ist so ein komisches Sound-Damp-Material dran. Autsch.
Aller Krieger ist stabil, das macht mir keine Gedanken.
Mop-Mop-XD, Dankeschön für den Sub. Muscle-Breaker, Huge-Subscriptions-Tier-1.
Ja, und so, was ich auch nicht übersehen habe. Akustik-Schaum, genau.
Dann kriege ich Tür gegen den Kopf.
Ich will eigentlich nur das Original einmal sehen. Au, das tut weh.
Autsch, das tut aber echt weh. Das ist voll in den Kopf geknallt, da wo nicht der Schaumstoff war.
Das ist ja wirklich schmerzhaft aus.
Oh nein, Monkathos.
Sag mal, was empfiehlt mir YouTube wieder für Kram? MonkaS.
Warum kriege ich nicht mal meine gescheite Empfehlung wie sonst immer?
Hab ich irgendwas geupdatet, was ich nicht hätte updaten sollen, oder?
Dann wird es aber schwierig, dass wir am Sonntag Aufwachen-Stream machen, wenn ich nur so einen Müll hier empfohlen kriege.
Was Empfehlungen gibt es nur noch nach Verifikation? Autsch.
Das kann doch überhaupt nicht sein. Dann würde ich jetzt nicht das hier empfohlen bekommen, weil ich das andere eben geguckt habe.
Ich weiß, dass ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Ich weiß, dass ich nicht eingeloggt bin, aber normalerweise hat YouTube trotzdem Customized anhand dessen, was wir im Stream geguckt haben.
Und ich hab meine History nicht gelöscht? Die sind wir noch da?
Hast du neue IP bekommen? Bestimmt, aber mit der IP hat das nichts zu tun.
Das ist doch alles Browser-History.
Oder was? Das geht doch nicht auf IP. Dann hätte ich doch nie den gleichen Kram bekommen die Wochen über.
Wenn nicht, müssen wir mal schauen, dass wir am Sonntag ein paar Videos gucken, dass die Empfehlung besser wird.
Cash gelöscht? Nee. Nee. Nicht wissentlich zumindest. Okay, also Leute, hier, Progress.
Es steht im Titel, Progress. Bam, nicht so viel sidetracken lassen.
Also, wir brauchen einen Thermostat. So, ich hab eine Thermostat-Klasse. Damit ist die Sache noch nicht getan.
Also, jetzt müssen wir den Mist, den wir hier erstmal haben, ist die Katze Wupp. Was für ein Ding?
Du meinst Wupp Katzor oder so? Ja, ist sie. Also, heißen tut sie Chico. Und frag mich nicht, warum eine Katze Chico heißt.
Hier sieht man sie noch ein bisschen besser an dem Moment. Habe ich... Ich finde auf meinem Desktop alles.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie Chico heißt. Der Chico ist ja eigentlich ein Männername.
Der ehemalige Besitzer, schräg schräg die ehemalige Besitzerin, man weiß es ja nicht, die ist aus dem Tierheim,
hat gedacht, Chico ist ein guter Name für eine Katze. Das ist ganz schön dicke Wurscht, die Katze.
Aber die ist halt auch wirklich so dicke Wurscht. Okay, Moment, ich muss... Progress Leute, Progress.
So, weiter. Sich so viel ablenken lassen. Also, jetzt müssen wir den Kram hier unten umwursten,
dass das hier in der Klasse drin ist. Also, schauen wir mal. Was brauchen wir denn da?
Ich glaube, wir kriegen nichts auf die Reihe. Wir leben in einer modernen Welt, da geht das.
Ja, aber Chico ist ja... War Frau und ist Frau. Ist Mädchen und war Mädchen, ist Mädchen.
Ist weibliche Katze und bleibt und ist weiter weibliche Katze.
Magst du wieder am Prokazinieren? Ja, das sieht so aus. Okay, also, was brauchen wir jetzt dafür,
dass wir den Kram jetzt mal ordentlich basteln? State Topic, Config Topic, Command Topic.
Also, Name, in dem Fall Heizung, haben wir... Das muss ich dann nachher irgendwie zusammenbauen,
da bin ich mir jetzt noch nicht so ganz sicher. Warum? Was hat denn hier für Schmerzen?
Was ist denn jetzt das Problem? Hab ich aus vergessen. Ah, ah, ah, ich hab den Namespace.
Übrigens, wir können eine neue C-Sharp-Feature verwenden. Passt mal auf, Poggers.
Das ist ein C-Sharp-10-Feature. Man kann jetzt sagen, using Namespace. War das nicht so?
Nee, wie ging das? Oder einfach nur Namespace? Moment. C-Sharp using Namespace.
Wie ging das nochmal? C-Sharp 6? Using... Wo ist jetzt? Nichts sicher.
Dotnet 6, C-Sharp using Namespace. Nee, using Namespace ist C++. Global. Nee, Moment.
Wie ging das nochmal? Namespace. Aber das geht, das geht jetzt auch. Namespace. Wie geht das?
Zeig, meine Güte. Using. Global using. Global using. Global using. Nee, nee, das war es nicht.
Das war es nicht. Okay, ich weiß nicht. C-Sharp. Dotnet 6. Namespace. Feature.
Dotnet 6. Global using. Nee, nee. Ich will ihm sagen, welchem Namespace das ist.
Kann man das mal weglassen? Der macht es jetzt trotzdem. Ich glaube, man kann es jetzt weglassen, den default Namespace.
Using Heizschirm. Einfach so? Okay, so genau habe ich es noch nicht durchgestiegen, aber zumindest braucht man das Using drum herum nicht mehr.
Was auch immer. So, Name, Klein, Device-Info. Das Device-Info müssen wir uns irgendwo speichern.
Okay, was für Topics brauchen wir denn jetzt, damit wir die ganzen Sachen nach Home Assistant schicken können? Command-Topic gibt es nicht. Config-Topic gibt es. State-Topic gibt es auch.
Also fangen wir mal an. State-Topic ist in dem Fall das da, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das mit ID nicht so einfach funktioniert, weil ID ist die Device-Info.
Habe ich das gemacht? Moment, ich bin gerade ein bisschen verwirrt. Was habe ich hier gebaut? Identify. Ach, das ist ein Array. Warum ist das ein Array?
Das sagt ja. Was soll das? Da müsste ich jetzt ja sowas machen. Das ist ja vollkommen... Das ist ja mega... Das ist ja mega hässlich.
Nein, das machen wir so nicht. Das ist doch kacke. Guckt euch das mal an. Ich lasse das jetzt mal... Okay, Name ist aber richtig so.
Okay, State-Topic. Dann brauchen wir Command-Topic. Wobei ein Command-Topic gibt es nicht. Config-Topic brauchen wir. Config-Topic ist... Das habe ich doch hier irgendwo gesehen.
Wo publish ich denn den Kram? Config. Hier, da. Das da. Config-Topic. Das finde ich mal mega abartig hier gemacht. Das kann man nicht zulassen.
Ich meine, natürlich könnte ich sowas hier machen. Aldi gleich... Ich meine, das ist jetzt erstmal vielleicht besser. Aber trotzdem ist das nicht schön.
Das muss ich irgendwie einfacher rauskriegen. Die Frage ist eh, ob ich das überhaupt brauche. Müssen wir mal gucken. Config-Topic haben wir. Jetzt müssen wir diesen ganzen anderen Mist festlegen.
Also wir brauchen noch... Config ist das, wo ich es initial hinschicke an Home Assistant. State ist das, wo ich sage, Mode, Temperatur und so gedürnt. Dann brauchen wir noch... Was haben wir denn da noch?
Temp. Was? Ein Temp-Command-Topic. Die Home Assistant Leute. Temp. Da nenne ich es halt Temp-CMD-Topic meinetwegen. So und dann haben wir noch ein Mode-CMD-Topic.
Mode. So und das ist jetzt Mode. Das müssen wir glücklicherweise nur einmal setzen und dann kann ich es wieder vergessen. Bis zum nächsten Stream müsste ich das eh nehmen.
So, ID. Name. Ok, das sieht gut aus. Und dann haben wir jetzt noch ein Temp-CMD. Was ist das da? F. Aclia F. Ok, wunderbar. Hingeschrieben und vergessen. Gut ist.
So, also wir machen jetzt quasi das, was wir hier manuell gemacht haben. Mal schön, dass man das halbwegs benutzen kann.
So, das war es doch erstmal. Das lasse ich aber mal hier drin stehen. Ok, damit ich jetzt Commands bekomme. Also was ich schreiben will ist folgendes.
Ich will sowas hier, ich will das Thermostat anlegen und dann will ich sowas sagen wie Thermostat on, keine Ahnung, an on Temp-Command oder so.
Und dann will ich irgendwas machen. Ja, sowas wie Temp und dann setzen oder so. Sowas in der Richtung. Leicht. Mal schauen. Das heißt wir brauchen oder wir machen das mit einem Event.
Warum alles mit Unterstrich am Anfang? Ist das ein C-Sharp-Ding? Naja, nicht wirklich. Das ist sowas, das hat sich Microsoft ausgeschrieben.
Ich glaube sogar im offiziellen C-Sharp-Naming-Guide ist es gar nicht so. Aber es hat sich so eingebürgert, dass man alles was private ist, einen Anderscore davor macht.
Weil ansonsten müsste man, um das zu kennzeichnen, dass man auch wirklich quasi private member hier meint oder private field meint, müsste man auch sowas hier davor schreiben.
Also muss man nicht wirklich, der würde das auch so erkennen. Aber wenn ich es einfach nur ID nennen würde, dann ist jetzt so erstmal nicht klar, ist das irgendwie eine Variable hier drinnen oder ist das irgendwie was global oder was klassenmäßiges.
In modernen Apps macht niemand mehr Underscore. Tja, bin ich halt nicht modern. Aber da habe ich so meine Zweifel, dass das in modernen Apps keiner mehr macht. Ich sehe das laufen.
Im Discord keine Nachrichten kommen. Ja, der Bot ist wahrscheinlich wieder kaputt. Was macht man denn wenn man modern ist?
Wenn man modern ist, macht man Kebab Case. Kebab Case eh Beste. Kebab, ich vergesse immer was es war. Kebab Case ist nicht das mit dem Bindestrich dazwischen.
Vielleicht macht man, vielleicht macht man Gendersternchenstanz Underscore. Das wird sein ja.
Mode CMD Topic Innen. Und dann ist plus die Frage. So? So? So? So? Es ist ja auch nicht ganz klar.
Ach doch, das Kebab Case ist das mit dem Minus. Man schreibt einfach die war ohne Underscore.
Der Grund für den Underscore hat man ist doch hat man doch sogar ursprünglich mal erfunden dafür, dass man es einfacher erkennt.
Witzig, das mach ich Gendersternchen, Gender, Jender. Nee, ich weiß nicht. Ich finde das so schön ab.
Okay, also weiter im Text, ID.
Was sagt er hier?
Ah, it's never.
Ja.
He's never.
It's never used and can be converted to local variable.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher, ich brauch das bestimmt nochmal.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt haben wir die ganzen, die ganzen Grapler angelegt.
Jetzt können wir schauen, wie wir das hier hinbauen.
Also genau, so, hier will ich jetzt die neuen Commands bekommen.
Das heißt, wir machen jetzt noch ein, hier so ein Property, keine Ahnung, Action.
Action.
Hallo?
Was ist schon wieder für Spodermusik hier?
Äh, so, on temp command.
Ich brauch mal was anderes.
Kirby happy music.
Tü, tü, tü, tü, tü, tü, tü, tü, tü, tüm.
Jawoll.
White people happy.
Happy music.
Ich weiß, Microsoft hat ursprünglich schon gesagt, dass man das hier gar nicht mit
Anderscore machen sollte, aber irgendwie haben alle immer drauf geschissen.
Happy music.
Und jetzt will ich mich auch nicht mehr umgewöhnen.
Also on, so temp, keine Ahnung, neue Temperatur.
Was, was ein guter Datentyp, Datentyp für eine Temperatur.
Die Temperatur geht es von 5 bis 40.
Ah.
Ich wette jetzt nichts anderes ein.
So on temp command, das heißt, wir können jetzt sowas hier tatsächlich machen.
Sollte funktionieren, jawoll.
Ähm.
Neues, neue, neue temp.
Schauen, ob das funktioniert.
U in 8.
Ich glaube, sowas hat sie schattlich. Wir sind ja nicht in C++.
Aber ein U-Short ist klau.
Warte mal, ist ein Short 8 oder 16?
16.
Ein Byte könnte ich nehmen, Byte?
Einfach ein Byte?
Gibt es ein U-Byte? Gibt es sowas?
Nee, oder?
Ist es ein U-Char? Nein, sowas gibt es.
Moment, der hat sowas, die schattlich unsigned Byte.
Gibt sowas nicht?
Der Chain-Lore ist da, na dann.
Ach, Byte ist 0 bis 255 und S-Byte ist signed.
Ah, Pfeiffer-Time, also sprich, standardmäßig ist Byte, er gibt ja auch Sinn.
1 gibt es ja bei einem Byte nicht, alles klar.
Dann ist das jetzt unser Temperatur-Data-Type, wunderbar.
So, on temp.
So, dann können wir die ganzen Kram jetzt subscriben.
MQTT-Client, subscriben zu.
Mode-Topic.
Und wenn es da eine neue Message gibt, machen wir was?
Und subscriben zu Temp-Topic.
Und wenn es da was Neues gibt, machen wir was?
Nämlich, wir sagen, on temp-Command aufrufen und zwar mit...
Ja, das muss dann ein Byte sein.
Message parsen als Byte.
Gut, wenn alles funktioniert... Ach so, Moment, nee.
Kann auch gar nicht, kann auch gar nicht funktionieren.
Kann ja gar nicht funktionieren, ich Announce ja noch nichts und ich hab's eben gelöscht hier im Home Assistant.
Ich hab's ja rausgeschmissen.
Also, gut, dann lassen wir das jetzt erstmal so.
Müsste eigentlich funktionieren.
So, und jetzt brauchen wir noch sowas wie Announce.
Also, woran das dann dem Home Assistant mitteilt, dass es da ist.
Also, diesen ganzen Schmodder hier.
So, so passt das eigentlich.
Also, Public Void.
Wir nennen es einfach Announce.
Wenn man noch richtig schreiben könnte, wäre auch wunderbar.
So, weil dann kann ich das Ganze nämlich so machen, dann brauch ich den Müll hier nicht.
Alles weg damit.
Dann kann ich jetzt nämlich einfach sagen...
Thermostat Announce.
So, fertig.
Und jetzt haben wir dieses unlesbare, ekelige Zeug zu was halbwegs Lesbarem gemacht.
Jetzt ist mir nur noch nicht ganz klar, ob's funktioniert.
So, jetzt mal schauen.
So, das kommentieren wir mal wieder ein.
Was versuchst du eigentlich zu bauen?
Ich hab's gerade gelöscht, ich kann's dir nicht zeigen.
Ich exportier meine Heizung nach Home Assistant und zurück.
Also sprich, ich hab in meinem Home Assistant dann Thermostat.
Was jetzt nicht geht, weil ich hab's grad gelöscht.
Ich hab dann einen Thermostat, da kann ich dann rumstellen.
Und das wird dann zurück gesendet.
Also erst mal wird exportiert, dass es Thermostat gibt.
Wenn ich an den Thermostat rumklicke, dann geht es zurück an meine Heizung.
Ich hab in Raspberry Pi eine Heizung im Keller hängen.
Er empfängt das Ganze und gibt das dann an die Heizung weiter.
Das funktioniert auch.
Ich brauch jetzt irgendwie ein ordentliches Gui.
Seit wann haben wir Badges?
Ja, seit gestern.
Seit gestern, du hast nichts Großartiges verpasst.
Okay, die macht kein Jason Rest.
Die Heizung?
Nee.
Und die Steuerung im Raspberry Pi auch nicht.
Das ist Telnet.
Ey komm, das ist Heizungsshit.
Weißt du, das ist irgendwie halbwegs aktuell und hat irgendwie eine harte TP Rest API oder
sowas.
Das ist Telnet.
Und hier haben wir das, was es sendet an die Heizung dann unten drunter.
Das haben wir auch schon ausprobiert, das funktioniert.
Das ist Telnet.
Also ich muss jetzt einmal per MQTT an Home Assistant annuncen, dass es eine Heizung gibt
und dann das Zurück Übersetzen in Telnet an die Heizung.
Websocket Connection mit der Heizung, das wär's jetzt.
Richtig moderner.
Guck hier, ich sag doch, ich brauch die ID.
Ich wusste, dass ich die ID brauch.
ID.
Bäm.
Name.
Wobei eigentlich bin ich blöd, ne?
Eigentlich könnte ich doch einfach sagen, ID, ich brauch das eh nur einmal.
Machen einfach ID.
So was hier.
Auch wenn mir das nicht gefällt, dass man das aus dem Array holen muss.
Aber mein Ding.
ALDI underscore und jetzt hier machen wir hier Name rein.
So.
Und jetzt kann ich hier einfach bei allem anstatt das da jetzt einfach ALDI hinschreiben.
So gut ist.
Weil die ALDI setzt sich ja eigentlich daraus zusammen.
Das ist Rider.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich hab die Frage nicht gesehen.
Das ist Rider.
Das ist Rider 21.2.1.
Also was halbwegs aktuelles.
Wenn nicht sogar das aktuelle.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob es auch was aktuelleres gibt.
Das ist das aktuelle.
Das kostet aber was.
Das ist nicht kostenlos.
Aber du kannst 30 Tage Testversion machen, die man natürlich danach sofort kaufen sollte.
Aber wenn man das nicht will, es gibt auch inoffizielle Scripts auf GitHub, um die Trial
Period zu resetten.
Aber die kann ich natürlich auf keinen Fall empfehlen zu benutzen.
Ich habe einen Key.
Ich habe wirklich den Key.
Ich habe es euch gezeigt das letzte Mal.
Ich habe einen Key.
Ich habe nicht nur einen Key, ich habe das Ultimate Pack, also dieses komplette Desktop
Package.
Das ist so 179 im Jahr oder so.
Deine Heizung zum Raspberry Pi.
Genau.
Es ist.
Nein, nein, nein.
Es ist nicht.
Es ist nicht seriell.
Die Heizung zum Raspberry Pi ist so ein proprietäres Kabel vom Hersteller.
Das ist das Kabel vom Raspberry Pi zur Heizung.
Das ist so ein proprietäres Ding mit Infrarot-LEDs.
Dieses ganze, diese ganze Heizungssteuerung Sache ist genauso wie Tür-Gegensprecher-Anlage.
Das ist komplett schwarze Magie und die Hersteller haben auch überhaupt kein Interesse daran,
da was dran zu ändern.
So, das muss ich jetzt nicht noch mal schreiben.
Da kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, Mode, CMD Topic.
Jetzt geht das nämlich schon gleich besser.
Mode.
Ne, einfach.
Ach Quatsch.
State Topic.
Wir sortieren das mal.
Wir machen mal die Commands zusammen.
Das braucht Temp, Temp, Command.
Der Kölbimusik, werde ich schon wieder nervös bei.
Das neue Spülmaschine hat eine Rest-AP.
Tja, sowas modernes habe ich noch nicht.
Meine Spülmaschine hat gar keine AP und meine Heizung hat eine Telnet-Verbindung.
Über irgendein proprietäres Kabel wohlgemerkt.
Null.
Ne, für sowas hier ist es zur Integration ganz cool.
Es gibt bestimmt schon ein fertiges Home Assistant Plugin dafür.
Da kannst du dann in deinem Home Assistant dich notifien lassen, wenn die Spülmaschine
fertig ist oder so.
Stelle ich mir eigentlich ganz sinnvoll vor, wobei man sagen muss, Spülmaschine fertig
und Waschmaschine fertig und so gibt es so viele Varianten, wie man das nachrüsten kann.
Von einem Rüttel-Sensor bis einer Steckdose, die den Stromverbrauch misst, bis ein Sensor
an der Tür oder was auch immer.
Also da gibt es total viele Möglichkeiten.
Hitzesensor, ja, da gibt es wirklich ganz viele Möglichkeiten, das zu machen.
Min-Temperatur, Max-Temperatur, vielleicht sollte ich das hier auch am Anfang noch übergeben
lassen.
Das machen wir optional.
Ich finde es zwar meistens nicht so geil, wenn ich Constructors habe und 5 Spiliaden.
Ach komm, scheiß drauf, das ist eh nur für meine Heizung.
Will auch sonst außer mir eh keiner verwenden.
Was hat der überhaupt für Schmerzen?
Namespace does not correspond to file location.
Should be Heiz-Champ.
Was?
Ich glaube Ryder kommt mit dem neuen Namespace Feature noch nicht so ganz klar, habe ich
das Gefühl.
Ich glaube das ist ein bisschen, warum ist denn hier ein Leerzeichen dazwischen?
So, da ist viel besser.
Ich glaube Ryder hat damit noch Probleme.
So, Min-Temperatur, 5 Max-Temperatur, 35, Template passt, off, on.
Das sollten wir tatsächlich noch in Enum für machen, für den Betriebsmodus.
Public, Enum, keine Ahnung.
Schrei, schrei, habe ich mich da nicht verschrieben?
Hat man das wirklich Thermostat?
Thermostat.
Ja, das schreibt man so.
Englisch.
Ha, tatsächlich.
Cool, ich habe mich verschrieben.
Also sollten wir das irgendwie Mode nennen oder so und Mode gibt es im Prinzip nur off
Heat.
Und dann brauchen wir, das brauchen wir irgendwie zum Setzen, Mode, Mode, Mode, perfekt.
Gut, ich würde sagen das müsste eigentlich so funktionieren, wie ich das jetzt gebaut
habe.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Mal zur Sicherheit, ich mache mal kurz, der wartet mal bevor er sich ausschaltet.
So, wenn jetzt alles funktioniert, dann sollte ich hier wieder ein neues Device bekommen.
Was sagt Heiz-Champ und sollte einen Thermostat Entry, einen Climate Entry haben?
Schauen wir mal.
Bam.
SpeedChamp.org, da kommt ein Engine X.
Tja.
Warum kommt da überhaupt ein Engine X?
Warum kommt, warum kommt denn da ein Engine X?
Wie, wie haben, wie habe ich das nochmal genannt?
SpeedChamp?
Wie, wie hieß, wie hieß mein, mein SpeedChamp?
Die URL, die wir mal verwendet haben, wisst ihr das vielleicht noch?
Zwar nicht SpeedChamp.org, oder?
Das was ich mit dem Noel gebastelt habe.
War das?
Ich frage mich nur, ob ich nicht vielleicht noch, nicht dass ich irgendeinen Server vergessen
habe, wo da drauf lief, das SpeedChamp.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Nee, ich glaub nicht.
Warum hab, warum hab ich das nicht in der History?
Ich glaub, meins war Punkt.com, oder?
Ich glaub, ich hatte SpeedChamp.com.
Cuddyworks?
Ach, kann das sein, dass die Domain abgelaufen ist?
Ich hab die Domain, glaub ich, nur für einen Monat geklappt, oder auch nicht?
Nee, hab ich, vielleicht ist meine Domain abgelaufen.
Warte mal.
Mal kurz gucken, er hat doch ein Video hochgeladen, wo wir perprogrammt haben.
Ich glaub, meine Domain ist abgelaufen.
Nee, nicht mein zweites Semester.
SpeedChamp.org, tatsächlich.
Lull, meine Domain ist abgelaufen.
Und irgendjemand hat sich gleich die Domain gekrappt, Alter.
Na, helle Güte.
WhoisSpeedChamp.org.
Damn cheap.
Engine X.
Nee, wisst ihr, was es ist?
Ich weiß, was es ist.
Leute, ich weiß, woran es liegt.
Ich hab die Domain, die ist immer noch mir.
Die Domain ist immer noch mir.
Und ich hab die IP nicht geändert.
Und irgendjemand hat halt den Server bei Hetzner bekommen mit meiner IP, die ich damals hatte.
Das kann ja sein, die vergeben die IPs ja doppelt.
Und der Typ, der die IP jetzt bekommen hat, der hat da halt gerade einen Engine X drauflaufen.
Der wird sich wundern, wenn er Zugriffe von SpeedChamp.org,
wenn er in seinem Log sieht, dass SpeedChamp.org auf ihn auflöst.
Das muss ich nachher mal wegmachen.
Ich muss es nachher auf irgendeine andere IP umstellen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof jetzt.
Doof jetzt.
So, Leute, es funktioniert nicht.
Warum funktioniert es nicht?
Weil ich komplett vergessen habe, das per MQTT rauszusticken.
Lul, Lul, Alter, Lul.
So, erst mal ein bisschen ausgerastet.
Ich stehe übrigens immer noch dazu. Lul, V, größer, Keck, V.
Ah, ich sehe ein Lost-Abonnent. Exquisite.
Hast du gestern auch beim Lost geguckt?
Oder hast du auch festgestellt, dass World War 3 eindeutig der größte Battlefield-Konkurrent aller Zeiten ist?
Also das hat mich schon hart überzeugt, das Game.
Ich habe auch nur eine Viertelstunde geguckt und habe festgestellt, was ein Kack-Game.
Aber der Keck-V-Mensch ist tot.
Ja, das ist doof, aber der Lul-V-Mensch ist auch tot, falls du das nicht mitbekommen hast.
Also die Leute hinter Keck-V und hinter Lul-V sind beide tot.
Pepehands.
Ja.
Das ist TotalBiscuit.
Der ist, glaube ich, schon vor 2-3 Jahren gestorben.
Und das ist, ich weiß gar nicht, wie der Typ in echt heißt.
Elrisitas.
Wie heißt der denn in echt?
Juan. Juan Roya Borja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das so ausspricht. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, leider. Der ist erst letztens gestorben vor 2 Monaten oder so.
Leider.
Also ich hätte beiden gewünscht, dass sie noch eine ganze Weile am Start sind.
Gerade TotalBiscuit. Weil Elrisitas war ja schon eine ganze Ecke älter.
Aber TotalBiscuit, der war so alt wie ich.
Es sind E. Ich bin übelst verwirrt zurück.
Die letzten Jahre sind total viele Leute gestorben.
Also so E-Sport-Leute, die man kennt. Die jünger waren als ich.
InControl ist gestorben. Das war das StarCraft-Caster.
TotalBiscuit ist gestorben. Internet Hulk, wer den noch kennt.
Overwatch ist gestorben.
Ich habe bestimmt noch ein paar, die ich vergessen habe.
Wo ich mir immer gedacht habe, what the fuck. Die sind jünger als ich.
Und geben alle die Löffel ab.
Meine Uhr tickt. Nicht Chat soll ich euch mal was sagen.
Nicht nur meine Uhr tickt. Eure auch.
Jede Uhr tickt.
Deswegen noch eine viel bessere Sache.
Deswegen ist es ja auch wichtig, dass man realisiert, was einem Spaß macht, was einem gefällt.
Um davon möglichst viel machen zu können.
Und nicht sein Leben mit ich arbeite von morgens bis abends zu verschwenden.
Natürlich muss man so viel arbeiten, wie man braucht an Kohle.
Ja, keine Frage. Aber es wird keiner sagen, kurz bevor er irgendwie stirbt.
Oder sich noch mal Gedanken darüber macht. So, fuck. Hätte ich mal mehr gearbeitet.
Ja. So sieht es aus.
Ok. Jetzt mal wieder zu etwas erfreulicheren Themen. Nämlich meine Heizung im Home Assistant.
Es funktioniert nicht, weil ich das Ganze nicht rausgeschickt habe.
Also MQTT Client. Wo ist er denn?
Aha. Den habe ich gar nicht gespeichert.
MQTT Client. Publish.
Auf das Konfig Topic.
Mein Jason.
Zack. Geht nicht. Weil.
Tu String fehlt wahrscheinlich.
Na, das hätte man auch mal überladen können, oder?
Das hatte Microsoft für uns doch mal machen können, Jason Object zu überladen.
Das ist automatisch zu stringt.
Ok. Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Wenn alles funktioniert, sollte in meinem Home Assistant jetzt ein Device aufgetaucht sein.
Nämlich der Heiz Champ. Und es funktioniert.
Der Heiz Champ ist am Start. Er hat eine Eintrag, die sich Heizung nennt.
Zack. Bäm. Da sind wir. Unknown. Unknown.
Na.
Richtiger Kokona Style hier.
Aber es funktioniert.
Jetzt muss ich nur noch Default.
Default Value setzen. Aber das funktioniert schon mal.
Leute, ihr müsst zugeben. Das ist doch jetzt eine ganze Ecke.
Lesbarer.
Als das, was ich am Anfang fabriziert habe, oder?
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob die Commands ankommen, die ich schicke.
Nee, also Temperatur.
Die Commands, die ich schicke,
kommen nicht an.
Warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Warum kommen die nicht an?
Ich.
Temp Command Topic.
Die sollten eigentlich ankommen.
Was ist hier los? Warum geht das nicht?
Was ist hier?
Weil der Minwert 5 Grad ist vielleicht.
Oder auch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich backt das einfach rum, wenn gar keine Werte gesetzt sind.
Das kann schon sein.
Deswegen setzen wir jetzt vielleicht erst mal ein paar Default Werte.
Würde ich sagen.
Was hat er hier für Schmerzen?
Nonnullable Property on Temp Command ist Uninitialized.
Ich habe keine Nullable Sachen an.
Oder von mir.
Na gut, dann schicken wir jetzt gleich noch in die Default Payload hinterher.
Und zwar.
Moment, ich muss das Ganze mal rückgängig machen.
Control S Org hier.
Das da brauchen wir jetzt nochmal.
Da schicken wir gleich noch ein paar Default Werte hinterher, bevor wir irgendwas machen.
Statemessage und gucken dann, ob es funktioniert.
Hallo, ich will es einkommentieren.
Ah, nice.
So Publish auf.
Das muss jetzt nicht auf Konfig Topic, sondern auf das State Topic.
Jason, Serializer, das da.
Ok, schauen wir mal.
Jetzt sollte er zumindest schon mal Default Value setzen.
Macht er aber nicht.
Warum nicht?
Hat er keinen Bock.
She baited.
Was mache ich verkehrt?
Habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Massive Gachi Bass am Start.
Passt doch mit 23,6.
Tatsächlich.
Ok, machen wir was anderes.
Sieben.
Da ich auch sehe, dass es funktioniert.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert.
Kaum. Kaum macht man es richtig.
Kann es sein, dass das irgendwie rumpackt?
Warum? Warum erkennt er jetzt auf einmal nicht?
Wenn man das ist Temp Temp Command Topic.
Und Mode Command Topic.
Das sollte er eigentlich erkennen, wenn ich da einen Knopf drücke im Web Interface.
Auf On macht er doch auch und Temperatur macht er auch.
Ah, 10,6.
Natürlich.
Das gibt einfach einen Fehler.
Der kann 10,6 nicht pasen als als bald.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Ich meine, ich kann es als Float passen als bei Carsten.
Aber das funktioniert.
Das ist doch bestimmt nicht so gedacht.
Ah, neue Temp 13.
Ok, das funktioniert.
Da verlasse ich mich aber wirklich jetzt ganz stark drauf, dass da auch nichts anderes reinkommt, sonst Crasheds.
Wobei es Crashed nicht.
Die MQTT Message geht halt dann kaputt.
Was ich mache, ich baue ein Thermostat, wo ich Sachen dran rumstellen kann und dann wird es an meine Heizung in den Keller geschickt.
500 EQ, ja.
Aber das passt.
Also guck mal, der schickt die Informationen, was ich eingestellt habe, schon mal zurück.
Das ist doch schon mal nice.
So, jetzt brauchen wir das Gleiche hier nochmal.
Wir haben On Temp Command.
Das ist, wenn ich sage, ich möchte eine neue Zieltemperatur einstellen.
Und jetzt brauchen wir On Mode Command.
Das ist ein Mode, gibt das.
Und das ist, wenn ich sage, ich will umschalten zwischen Heizen und nicht Heizen.
Das Wreckful keine Mode bekommen hat.
Das stimmt.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Wollten die nicht?
Ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern.
Die waren doch da ziemlich hinterher.
Die wollten doch.
Warum hatten da keins gekriegt?
Die haben doch, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, die wollten.
Ja, das ist wirklich schade, dass da keins gekriegt hat.
Weil das Emote, was zur Auswahl war, ist zu toxic.
Was?
Oh, ist das zu toxic?
Okay, was ist, was ist Wreck Age für ein Emote gewesen?
Das da?
Ja, wahnsinnig toxic.
Was ist daran denn toxic?
Er lacht in die Kamera.
Okay, ich weiß eh nicht.
Heutzutage ist alles toxic, Alter.
Heute weiß er echt nichts mehr.
Kannst das netteste Emote sein?
Irgendwas ist immer toxic.
Was ist denn daran toxic, bitte schön?
Oder jebaitet uns der Chainlure und er weiß gar nicht, warum das nicht genommen wurde.
Pepe ist toxic.
Nee, Pepe ist white power, nicht toxic.
Okay, man kann auch sagen, das ist toxic.
Pepe ist geheimer white power Kram.
Was auch, naja.
Ja, warum hat er das nicht genommen?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Switch.
Ja, stimmt.
Warum hat er, warum kriegt er, warum hat er kein Emote gekriegt?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen, aber gut.
Switch wird schon wissen, was sie machen.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich bin mir da manchmal nicht so ganz sicher.
Da hat er es erklärt.
Nee, das ist ganz was anderes.
Wahrscheinlich, ob man fragen kann, dass er nicht einverstanden ist.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber naja, er hatte ja das Emote schon auf der Plattform.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ach komm, auf Twitch blickst du eh nicht so genau durch.
Die englischsprachigen Wörter sind nicht so gut.
Im englischsprachigen Raum musst du sehr aufpassen, dass du nicht falsche Wörter sagst, die sich nur anhören wie bestimmte Wörter.
gleich vorbei. Der Eichler ist am Start, 25 Monat Dankeschön für den Sub. Massive Subscription
der Eichler hier. Okay, also on temp command, dann haben wir hier on mode command, so jetzt
müssen wir hier nichts parsen, jetzt müssen wir den, den Mode, oh wir können Big Brain
Time machen. Guck mal, hier kommt doch, Moment wie ist denn die Message was da reinkommt
wenn man den Mode switcht. So, Message, Message ist off und heat, glücklicherweise heißt
unser Inam genau off und heat, das heißt das können wir tatsächlich auch parsen glaube,
können wir sagen Inam, pars, als, als Thermostat Mode und zwar die Message. Oh, das funktioniert
ich glaube schon, dass das geht. Das ist jetzt aber richtig 5 hat Zeit. Groß, großer Kopf,
großer Gehirn, große Gehirnzeit, off, ne das funktioniert nicht, Mist, das wäre zu einfach
gewesen, wenn das funktioniert. Aber warum funktioniert das nicht? Wegen groß und klein,
wegen groß und Kleinschreibung vielleicht? Das, legt das an groß und Kleinschreibung?
Gibt das so wie Tri-Pars? Out, warm, Message. Cool. Was ist, wo ist das Problem? Was ist
denn jetzt schon wieder? Ja, zeig mir mal, zeig mir an, was ist das Problem? Was? Ach
so. Ja, ok, alles klar. So, warum, warum kann er das nicht parsen? Pals. Muss wahrscheinlich
groß und Kleinschreibung sein, denke ich mal. Das ist aber doof, dass es groß und Kleinschreibung
sein muss, das, das sackt. Kann man das nicht irgendwie überschreiben? Ignore Case, siehste,
das wegen, das wegen mag ich das.NET Framework, die haben so Sachen einfach dabei. Die haben
einfach, die haben einfach sinnvolle Sachen eingebaut und sie sind meistens auch da, wo
man sie sucht, das ist cool. Off, Hit, Bäm, wird gepasst, nice, GG Eats. Weißt du was
die Hetzer Server für eine Internetanbindung haben? Ne, du selbst kriegst glaube ich, glaube
ich nur einen Gigabit am Server, aber was Hetzer selbst dahinter für eine Internetanbindung
hat, das weiß ich nicht. Geh mal davon aus, dass sie kein Gigabit von Vodafone haben und
sonst nichts. Die werden schon ordentliche Glasfaserkabel haben, wahrscheinlich haben
sie sich irgendwelche Dark Fiber Sachen gemietet, die schon rumliegen, keine Ahnung, was weiß
ich, wie die das gemacht haben, aber ich glaube anbildungstechnisch hast du bei jetzt da keine
Probleme. Es sei denn du wirst gededost, dann ist es auch mal relativ schnell der Ofen aus.
Peering Policy, übrigens Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat, wenn ihr euch einen Hetzner Gutschein
sichern wollt, für 20€ Startguthaben könnt ihr abgreifen und euch registrieren und dann
mit meinem Code irgendwo im Benutzerprofil eingeben. Da könnt ihr euch 20€ Startguthaben
sichern, nur für Neukunden, aber davon könnt ihr schon 1-2 kleine Server für ein paar Monate
laufen lassen. Kleine Server, ich rede hier nicht von 32 Kerne oder sonst was. Ausrufezeichen
Hetzner im Chat, bam. Private Peerings, Frankfurt, übrigens nochmal so, Private Peerings heißt,
die stehen, Hetzner hat zum Beispiel im Dezix in Frankfurt ein Switch stehen, die einfachste
Variante und die Telekom auch und Freenut auch und 1&1 auch und Vodafone auch und die
nehmen einfach ein Kabel und stecken es von ihrem Switch an den Switch von Vodafone, das
ist Private Peering. Natürlich ist es in dem Fall nicht so einfach, aber im Prinzip ist
es so. Ich hab sogar so ein paar Peering-Kabel schon mal gesteckt im Dezix, da ist es kein
Hexenwerk, aber normalerweise steckst du nicht ein Kabel vom Switch da irgendwie quer durch
den Gang, das erlauben die natürlich nicht, das musst du schon über die machen, aber
im Prinzip ist es so, du stöpst das Kabel von deinem Switch zu dem anderen Provider.
Als ich beim Provider gearbeitet hab, das war sogar glaube ich noch während meiner Ausbildungszeit,
da waren wir ein paar Mal im Dezix und ich hab damals noch, ich weiß nicht wie es heute
ist, ich hab damals noch durch die Röhre gepasst, na klar ich würde heute auch noch
durch die Röhre passen, die haben so eine Waage am Eingang, da musst du in so eine Röhre
rein, die wird zugemacht und dann wirst du gewogen, dass du beispielsweise nicht irgendwie
eine Bombe reinbringst und dann wieder rausgehst, weil die wiegen dich und wenn du rausgehst
und wiegst dann quasi bedeutend weniger als was du mit reingenommen hast, dann lassen
sie dich nicht raus.
Du regelmäßigen Datenaustausch von mehr als 2 Gigabit, nein das hab ich nicht.
Klar gibt's heute noch, ich war schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr drinnen, wenn du öfters
schon drinnen warst die letzte Zeit und das gesehen hast, ja dann gibt's das anscheinend
noch.
Hast du auch Lust auf ein Machine Learning AI Projekt, fänd ich spannend, kommt drauf
an auf was.
Wir haben ja schon mal, ja eine Sache die wir mal gemacht haben im Stream ist Personenerkennung
in einem Kamerafeed.
Also nicht zwischen dem wiegen Kacken, ich glaube so genau ist das ganze nicht, ich glaube
du kannst schon scheißen, wobei ich mir gar nicht mehr sicher bin ob da ein Klo drinnen
war und ob du zum Kacken nicht rausgehen musstest, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nur noch, also wie gesagt zu diesen ganzen Peering Geschichten, wo hab ichs denn
jetzt hier, also ich weiß das insofern aus eigener Erfahrung, dass das im Prinzip relativ
simpel ist, ne, das ist ein Kabel vom Switch oder vom Router zu einem anderen Anbieter seinem
Router, weil wir hatten damals, also ich musste damals das Peering mit Freenet stecken, ich
weiß nicht ob es Freenet noch gibt, gibt's Freenet noch?
Ja anscheinend gibt's sie noch, die haben aber nicht mehr dieses hässlich gelbe Logo
von früher.
Freenet hatte früher ein anderes Logo, definitiv nicht das, Freenet hatte früher noch glaube
ich so ein hässlich, ja sowas da, genau sowas in der Richtung hatten die früher, irgendwas
gelbes genau.
Ich kann mich doch dran erinnern, wir haben, wir waren da ein paar Mal und einmal, also
da kannst du ja Racks mieten und einmal war da Storage, was ist Storage, das Ding Storage
zu nennen ist zu viel, die haben da ne, ich hab nicht mal Freenet gearbeitet, ich hab
das Peering gesteckt zu, heißt das Peering oder ist das Peering, wie spricht man das
eigentlich aus?
Peering, Peering, Peering, Peering, Peering, Peering, Peering, Peering, Peering, Peering,
ich sag nicht wo ich gewesen bin, aber ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab quasi den Ablink,
wenn du so willst, ja nicht Ablink, das Peering gesteckt zu Freenet damals, deswegen weiß
ich, dass das im Prinzip einfach ein Stück normales Kabel ist zum Router vom anderen
Anbieter.
So und wir hatten da mal einen Storage im Rack beim Dead 6, das ist doch wie gesagt
Storage zu nennen ist ein bisschen zu viel, das war halt so ne ganz normale 2 HE Kiste
mit ein paar Festplatten drinnen und wow, warum ist das jetzt so laut und KS und da
haben sie uns damals als Azubis hingeschickt, weil das Storage Probleme macht, ich weiß
auch nicht warum man da überhaupt einen Storage hat, kein Schimmer, zumindest war das Ding
anscheinend kaputt, also konnte es nicht mehr Remote managen, hat sich nichts getan, also
was haben wir gemacht, Rebooted, 5 Minuten, Bless RNG gebetet, wieder eingeschaltet und
es hat funktioniert, easy, aber was nicht so easy war, 2 Tage später war das Storage wieder
nicht erreichbar, sind wir wieder hingefahren, ja das war noch Zeit, das war die Turnschuhe
der Administrator Zeit, seit wann gibt es das bei Google, was, also bei uns im Rechenzentrum
gibt es auch kein Klo, ich kenne ehrlich gesagt auch kein Rechenzentrum mit Klo, selbst
bei den ganzen, in Frankfurt, da wurde dir quasi, dich einmieten kannst, wo du da halt
einen Raum bekommst mit Klimaanlage und Netzwerkports, manchmal auch mit fertigen Racks schon, die
haben auch alle keine Klos innen drin, da musste alle immer raus auf den Gang und dann
irgendwo kacken, in der Kleierstraße ist das Klo richtig abartig gewesen, weiß nicht ob
da schon mal einer die Ehre hatte in Frankfurt hinzugehen, Kleierstraße 90, ja da ist auch
eke nix, genau, glaub nicht, dass es da Bilder von innen gibt oder, innen vielleicht, ne da
gibt es keine Bilder von innen, aber der Boden kommt hin, ne da gibt es keine Bilder von innen,
das Klo da ist richtig eklig, das ist so ein dunkles, persiftes Klo hinter einer Tür, wo
gefühlt irgendwie zweimal im Monat jemand reinguckt, alter das ist abartig das Kleierstraße
Klo gewesen, also wenn ihr mal dahin müsst geht da nicht aufs Klo, aber es ist auch kein
Problem, weil ihr habt vorne um die Ecke in den McDonalds, da ist zwar das Klo auch
nicht gut, aber besser als das Kleierstraße 90 Klo, ja ich weiß nicht, ich bin ein bisschen
side tracked worden wieder, minimal, wobei Leute heute bin ich verhältnismäßig selten
side tracked oder, in Nürnberg bei Hetzner gibt es im Co-Location Space einen Aufenthaltsraum
mit Klo, exellent, so muss das sein, aber die Playlist kann sich auch nicht entscheiden
wie auch die Musik wird oder nicht, ok wo machen wir jetzt weiter, also wir bekommen
jetzt die Info, dass wenn der Modus von der Heizung umgeschaltet werden soll oder die
Zieltemperatur von der Heizung, also die können sich wirklich nicht entscheiden mit der Lautstärke,
also kopieren wir das hier mal raus, pass, einfach nur pass, wenn es kaputt geht, geht
es halt kaputt, beste Variablenbenahmung E, alles klar, ich will das hier nicht reinschreiben,
das wird da ein bisschen zu unübersichtlich, aber man könnte es natürlich, weil ich brauche
eigentlich keine Variable, ich könnte es so schreiben, aber das finde ich ein bisschen
unübersichtlich, ich mache einfach so, ok, übrigens ein Tipp, den ich selbst eine Weile
nicht kannte, wo ich euch aber nicht raten würde, den wirklich zu benutzen, es gibt
manchmal die Situation, dass man Variablen so nennen will wie Schlüsselwörter in C sharp,
das geht halt nicht, aber was ich machen kann ist, ich kann ein Add davor machen, dann überschreibt
das das, also wenn ich eine Variable so nennen will wie das Schlüsselwort, was es schon
gibt, dann kann ich ein Add davor machen, und jetzt kann ich hier so drauf zugreifen,
aber ja, schön ist es nicht, das geht übrigens sogar mit einem if, war, if, add, aber er
sagt schon, das sollte man nicht machen, was so wie die Frau, die keinen iTunes Account
erstellen konnte, weil sie Boolean mit Nachname heißt, ja warum heißt man auch so, das ist
aber schon fail dann, das ist bestimmt irgendeine SQL Injection Vorsorge von Apple, dass das
nicht funktioniert, gut, jetzt soll ich Messages bekommen, wenn ich auf Web Interface rum klicke,
On Mode, neue Mode, Mode, Mode, so schauen wir mal, genau das war's, ja wundert mich,
wundert mich nicht, ok, neue Mode, off, on, und neue Temp, bam, wunderbar, so Step Size
sollte ich noch einstellen, weil Step Size 0,5 ist ein bisschen doof, machen einfach,
machen einfach Step Size, Step Size, wir machen mal, dass ich überprüfen kann, ob
das Step Size, ne, wobei, brauche ich überhaupt nicht, ich habe es noch im Frontend eingestellt,
ok, das passt eigentlich, was ich hier gebaut habe, mehr muss ich jetzt zumindest an der
Stelle nicht machen, das heißt, das funktioniert, so, jetzt muss ich das Ganze noch irgendwie
mit der Heizung verbinden, das wird jetzt ein bisschen komplizierter, kurz Chat gucken,
was im Unimodul Microservices sollten wir nachprogrammieren, was der Professor gezeigt
hat, er hat dann auf Heroku, das ist übrigens zumindest die mir bekannt, oder bekannteste,
also oldschooligste Software, ne, wie nennt man das, das ist ja nicht wirklich Software-Assist-Service,
so Deployment-Plattform, die konnte man, das war damals für Ruby on Rails, gab es da schon,
Heroku, und das haben die ganzen coolen Ruby on Rails Rockstar-Developer damals gemacht,
die haben alle ein Git-in-it gemacht, immer bei sich in irgendwelchen Webcasts, um zu
zeigen, Alter, ich bin der richtig coole Shit-User, und dann haben sie das gepusht dahin.
Craig Wilhelm, Dankeschön, 12 Monate Subscription, wenn du im Chat schreibst, du bekommst ab
jetzt einen Goldkeks, kannst du ja mal ausprobieren, alle mit 12 Monate und älter haben jetzt
ein Goldkeks mit Poggers Halskette, Gangster, Gangster-Style, also, äh, deployen aber String-Konkerts
für Esketen, bäh, stand das über die Argumentenliste zu mir, das macht man ja auch nicht, das
macht man ja auch nicht, das erinnert mich daran, an meine Berufsschule, da hatte der
Lehrer auch sowas programmiert, wo man den Bildschirm sperren konnte bei allen Leuten,
da hat er sich richtig gefeiert für, und man konnte den Bildschirm quasi, ähm, er konnte
sehen, was die Leute machen, er hat im Prinzip laufenden Screenshot gemacht und sich vorgeschickt,
das war richtig Easy-Mode-Programm, was er da gebaut hat, und das konntest du auch ganz
einfach abschießen, du musstest einfach gucken, auf welchem Port das Lokal läuft,
Teller aufmachen, und einfach random sinnlos Zeichen reinschreiben, dann ist das immer
gecrashed, und das hast du ja immer gesehen, dann hat's überall, wenn der Lehrer vorne
den Knopf gedrückt hat, hat's bei allen den Bildschirm gelockt, bloß halt bei denen,
die das wussten nicht, juck das, moin, exellent, so, Leute, mir fällt grad ein, mein Thermostat,
meine Thermostat-Klasse hat noch einen entscheidenden Flaw, wisst ihr auch was, also, ich hab, ich
hab ne Sache, ich hab ne Sache vergessen, ich kann jetzt, ich bekomm zwar Benachrichtigungen,
wenn einer hier die Knöppe drückt, aber ich bekomm keine Informationen rein, wenn sich
was an der Heizung ändert, also es könnte ja durchaus sein, gerade auch mal die, diese
Temperatur jetzt oder der State, denn der State kann sich ja ändern, zum Beispiel, wenn
einer in den Keller geht und dort die Heizung ausschaltet, warum bist du kein Software-Entwickler
geworden, naja, bin ich doch, vielleicht jetzt nicht die klassische Geschichte mit, ich sitz
den ganzen Tag vor der Java-IDE, aber ich würd sagen, mittlerweile mach ich bestimmt,
70, 80 Prozent, mir entweder Sachen angucken, die andere Leute programmiert haben oder
selbst drum basteln, allerdings, muss ich dazu sagen, was du gesagt hast, du meinst
wahrscheinlich, warum ich keine fachinformatische Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt hab, ja, gut,
das liegt daran, weil ich ja Ausbildung gesucht hab und das erste, wo ich was gefunden hab,
war fachinformatische Systemintegration und das hab ich dann auch gemacht, aber ich hab
damals schon gerne programmiert, was mir jetzt im Endeffekt auch zugute gekommen ist, weil
ich glaube, sonst könnt ich das gar nicht machen, aber das ist eh, mittlerweile, da
gibt's doch gar nicht mal so viele Unterschiede zwischen, die Abschlussprüfung ist zum größten
Teil gleich, es gibt, glaub ich, eine Aufgabe, die unterschiedlich ist zwischen Anwendungsentwicklung
und Systemintegration und bei den neuen weiß ich's nicht, es gibt jetzt ja zwei neue Fachinformatiker,
die glaub ich kaum einer ausbildet, wo die IRK, glaub ich, selbst nicht so genau weiß,
wofür die da sind, aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich kein großer Unterschied, also wir haben wirklich
durch die, das muss ich jetzt mal sagen, wir haben durch die Bankwerk alles random irgendwie
verteilt, wir haben Leute, die haben Informatik studiert, die sitzen bei uns im 24-7-Support
und klicken den ganzen Tag Jira-Tickets, also dafür weiß ich nicht, irgendwie weiß ich
da, dass das Studium gelohnt hat, wir haben Java-Entwickler, die administrieren jetzt Mail-Server,
wir haben ehemalige Netzwerk-Leute, die machen jetzt Tickets-Systeme, also das ist komplett
random bei uns, das ist ja auch das Gute, man steckt da nicht so fest, was man machen
muss, solange man Ahnung hat, bereust du kein Studium gemacht zu haben oder juckt es sich
manchmal in den Fingerlounge, nee, da bin ich zu faul für, ganz ehrlich, da bin ich
zu faul für, da bin ich zu faul, außerdem wozu, wozu, ich verdiene ganz okay 20 wahnsinnig
Pick-Stongs, ich könnte, wenn ich die Firma wechsle, das ist das einfachste mehr, will
ich gar nicht, es ist alles in Ordnung, ich verdiene ganz okay, ich sehe keinen Grund
dafür, was zu studieren, ich bin auch viel zu faul dafür, was sind die neuen, es gibt
zwei neue Fachinformatiker, die neuen IT-Berufe sind da, es gibt jetzt, halt dich fest, hier,
nee, warte, wo ist es denn, eh, ja alter IHK-Seite, da blickt doch keiner durch, es gibt zwei
neue Fachinformatiker, welche Fachinformatiker gibt es, genau, es gibt, Fachinformatiker
für digitale Vernetzung und Fachinformatiker für Daten- und Prozessanalyse, die sind jetzt
neu, Cloud-Stalls, ja, das geht halt ohne Probleme,
ja gut, Windows ist ja auch Panes-Champ, das kommt auf seinen Ausbildungsbetrieb an,
in der Berufsschule machst du das gar nicht, also ich habe es gar nicht in der Berufsschule
gemacht, vielleicht ist das mittlerweile drin, weiß ich nicht, scheint ja so bei manchen
zu sein und wenn du im Betrieb kein Linux hast, sondern nur Windows geklicke, dann wirst
du leider zum typischen planlosen Windows-Admin, es gibt nur ganz wenige Windows-Admins, die
wirklich Ahnung haben von dem, was sie machen, die meisten sind, ist zumindest meiner Erfahrung
nach so, die meisten kannst du eigentlich nicht gebrauchen, die haben die Logik von
Microsoft-Assistenten vielleicht kapiert, aber nicht, wie Sachen funktionieren.
Wir haben ein paar, die haben wirklich Ahnung, aber die haben auch nicht nur Ahnung von Microsoft,
was denkst du über sowas, denkst du, da kann man gut mit anfangen C-Sharp zu programmieren?
Also kurz Überblick, was ich dir empfehlen würde, um C-Sharp zu lernen, ist, also entweder
guckst du dir auf YouTube, Webcast und sowas zum Thema an, aber was ich dir empfehlen würde
ist, nimm das Openbook, das ist zwar von 2012, aber für die Basics reicht das, so, allerdings
ist nur bis Kapitel, also du brauchst das hier gar nicht alles hin, nur bis Kapitel 16
und XML kannst du überspringen, nur bis Kapitel 16, alles andere ist sinnlos.
Dann hast du die Basics, die Basics auf dem Mount Everest, ich kann das nicht, das hört
sich eher cringe an, wenn ich das sage, aber dann hast du die Basics soweit und dann kannst
du dir auch Webcasts und Sachen dazu angucken, wie man es jetzt, manche Sachen vielleicht
etwas moderner macht, weil das ist halt auf 2012, viele der coolen neuen Sachen sind da
noch gar nicht drin, aber das ist auch gar nicht so schlimm, das ist auch gar nicht so
schlimm, also die Basics sind ja immer noch die gleichen, das ist ein gutes Buch, das
habe ich damals auch gelesen, 2002 oder so, 2003, keine Ahnung, ist schon ein bisschen
her, den anderen Gramm brauchst du nicht, das ist ganz gut, Async Await Pattern Matching,
genau, dazu steht natürlich da noch nichts drin, XML ist ein riesen Painz Champ, ja,
mach dir ein Test-Account, du bekommst sowohl bei Microsoft 100€ Startguthaben als auch
bei Google, bei Google bekommst du glaube ich sogar 100€ im Monat frei, kann das sein,
oder gilt das nur für Google Apis, und bei AWS habe ich noch nie verwendet, aber AWS
hat auch sicher sowas, also ich habe bisher nur Google und Azure verwendet.
Ja, kann man auch, was ich halt an dem Openbook gut finde, dass es in Deutsch ist, es gibt
viele Leute, die lesen am besten, also wenn sie Bücher lesen ist es immer noch für sie
am besten, wenn es in der Native Speaker Language ist, auch wenn der Satz absolut nicht Native
Speaker Language war, aber das ist echt ganz gut, aber der Code ist natürlich auf Englisch.
Naja, ich überlege gerade ob wir noch weitermachen, weil ich bin irgendwie etwas erschöpft,
nicht von dem harten Progress, den wir heute gemacht haben, sondern einfach weil es 21.40
Uhr ist und ich die ganze Nacht gearbeitet habe, aber machen wir noch irgendwas, ja also
eine Sache ist noch komplett kaputt, was ich hier gebaut habe, ich kann ja noch gar nicht
was setzen, wenn sich das auf der Heizung ändert, also ich meine ich kann jetzt hier Temperatur
einstellen und sowas und auch den Modus umschalten, aber was ist denn wenn sich die Temperatur
auf der Heizung ändert, sagt ja keiner was Bescheid, moin, Port 20 Pascha, Vape Nation
wieder am Start hier, gibt es überhaupt noch eine XY Admins, ja, je nachdem was es ist,
ich sage nur SAP Admin oder VMA Admins oder sowas, das gibt es immer noch oder Kobold Programmierer,
also es gibt schon noch Bereiche, da ist es sinnvoll wenn du so dedicated Leute hast,
auch was Windows Zeug angeht, wie gesagt Windows Zeug ist einfach Massive Pains Jam, ich habe
heute übrigens ein Windows Notebook bestellt auf der Arbeit, die schieben mir immer Panik,
wenn die Leute Linux verwenden mittlerweile bei uns, ich werde es aber auch auf absehbare
Zeit weiter verwenden, weil bis das alles funktioniert unter Windows habe ich so meine
Zweifel, ob das überhaupt jemals funktionieren wird, ich habe heute ein Windows Notebook
bestellt und allein schon das Bestellen hat nicht richtig funktioniert, das ist ein guter
Start dafür, ich bin immer gespannt wie sie das machen wollen, ich habe eine Liste an
Sachen die ich brauche zum Arbeiten, zum Beispiel brauche ich Rider und ich hätte auch gerne
dass sie mir eine Lizenz verkaufen, was bestimmt wieder wahnsinnig viele Diskussionen dafür
sorgen wird, aber diesmal ist es bei mir relativ einfach, ich kann dafür sagen gut, wenn ihr
mir das nicht kauft, dann kann ich halt nichts machen, wir haben leider bisher nur Java-Gedöns
in der Softwareverwaltung drin, ich bin glaube ich so ziemlich der einzige der gerne.NET
verwendet, aber die 200 Euro sollten sie haben, so und ich brauche WSL2 auf jeden Fall am
besten noch, dass ich Docker-Stells noch verwenden kann, da bin ich mal gespannt wie sie das
hinkriegen wollen alles, das stimmt da hast du recht, bei VMWare musst du auch viel mehr
wissen als nur VMWare, das stimmt schon, wann soll das denn da sein, ich habe angekreuzt
nächste Woche Dienstag, ist ja nicht mein Problem wenn es nicht funktioniert, ich will
das eh nicht haben, ich benutze das nur um meinem Chef quasi einen Gefallen zu tun, ich
habe gar keinen Bock auf Windows Notebooks, kannst du mal eine Docker Tutorial auf YouTube,
ne auf YouTube nicht, außerdem es gibt richtig viele richtig gute Docker Tutorials auf YouTube,
was für ein Notebook hättest du gerne fürs Programmieren, eigentlich ist es mir fast
egal, Hauptsache es hat groß genug SSD und genug RAM, also 16G RAM sollten es schon sein
und sag mal so unter 256G SSD ist auch Müll, am besten vielleicht auch was mit mehr als
4 Kern, hast du eine Empfehlung, gute Frage, ich habe letztens was in den Empfehlungen gehabt
dazu, das war eine Docker Kurs, 4 Stunden oder so, keine Ahnung ob das gut ist, Complete
Docker, das da hatte ich letztens in den Empfehlungen, keine Ahnung ob das gut ist, aber es gibt
also Docker technisch gibt es wirklich saumäßig viel auf YouTube und da habe ich auch schon
viel Gutes gesehen, also da musst du dir irgendwas raus, da gibt es genug, Full Docker
Kurs 5 Stunden, da ist es nicht was, guck mal den kannst du dir in einem Arbeitstag
angucken und dann kannst du sagen guck mal hier, was ich heute schönes gemacht habe,
kannst du gut abrechnen, der macht gute Videos, von dem habe ich früher öfters mal Sachen
geguckt, der macht gute Videos, ich weiß nicht wie das jetzt ist, aber der macht gute
Videos, also das könnte man sich vielleicht mal geben, ansonsten, wie gesagt du siehst
schon, solange du nicht irgendwas von irgendwelchen Indern anguckst, weiß ich indische Programmier
Videos ist so ein Ding, naja, Peter von Microsoft, keine Ahnung, also ich will nicht sagen, dass
es keine guten indischen Programmier oder Software Entwicklungs Videos gibt, mir fallen
da jetzt aber keine ein, kennt jemand einen guten Channel, mit indischen Programmier Videos,
die halt, also englische, indische Programmier Videos, also mir fällt keiner ein, ich bin
mittlerweile aber auch schon da so vorgeschädigt, weil ich so viele Videos gesehen habe, die
halt mies waren, dass sobald ich in Videos, ist halt auch wieder Vorurteile pur, aber
es wurde halt oft genug bestätigt, wenn ich ein YouTube Video aufmache, wo es um Software
Entwicklung geht und ich höre einen mit indischem Akzent, bröche das meistens gleich aus
oder skipt mal kurz durch und stell dann fest, ah okay, geht vielleicht doch oder geht nicht,
diese eine Typ macht doch KI, das ist ganz gut, ja, diese einen Typ macht, das ist, also
viel vager gehts, glaub ich, mit der Aussage nicht mehr, oder, diese einen Typ macht doch
KI, das ist ganz gut, alles klar, boah, die können ihre Lautstärke von der Playlist echt
nicht, ja, nice, da gibt es ja anscheinend auch schon gescheite Videos, old on, old on,
so, also eine Sache hab ich hier noch ganz vergessen, richtig dumm, ich kann meine Heizung
ja, Kommandos schicken, aber ich kann nicht den umgedrehten Weg machen, weil meine Heizungsstatus
geändert hat, also brauchen wir hier noch irgendwie sowas, ähm, was ich schon nie probiert
hab, kann man erben von Bytes, oder Value Types kannst du, Value Types kannst du erben,
aber nicht sealed, feels bad, hab ich schon nie ausprobiert, also meine Heizung brauch
ja noch, ich hätte gern, was ist denn ein guter Temperature Type in.NET, Byte ist schon,
Byte ist schon irgendwie ziemlich cringe, cringe Brudi, oder wie sagt man das heute,
Lost, richtig cringe Byte für Temperatur zu verwenden, Temperature Type.NET, die haben
auch bestimmt irgendwas, String, auf die Idee bin ich auch noch gekommen, Musik ist richtig
paper please, was ist ein guter Temperature Type, egal wir bleiben bei Byte, schade, ich
will das, also wir brauchen jetzt hier, Current Temperature und wir brauchen auch noch, Target
Temperature, weil es könnte ja sein, dass jemand das an der Heizung ändert, ja und
wenn das jemand an der Heizung ändert, dann kommt das nicht über den Command vom Web
Interface rein, sonst wird einfach geändert und wenn das, oh Moment, Moment, das muss
ich publishen und wenn das einer ändert, dann muss ich eine Meldung ans Web Interface
beziehungsweise an Home Assistant schicken, dass das einer geändert hat, also da müsste
ich hier quasi den Setter irgendwie überschreiben, finde ich aber immer ziemlich eklig, ehrlich
gesagt, vielleicht mache ich das eher so, dass der alle 5 Sekunden neu publisht, aber
das braucht auch zu viel, ja richtiger, feels Corona man, einfach die kommulierte Temperatur
seit 1.1.1970, oh ja, das ist gut, die Temperatur in UTC, wie soll das überhaupt aussehen
die Temperatur in UTC, fällt mir jetzt, kann ich mir jetzt keine gute Darstellung überlegen
wie eine Temperatur in UTC aussehen soll, was denn, 19 Grad plus 1 oder was, nee, Moin
X-Factor hast du gesehen, du hast einen goldenen Keks, guck mal, du bist nämlich schon auch
über 2 Jahre am Start, alle über einem Jahr bekommen jetzt einen goldenen Keks und ich
bin gerade dabei noch die bisschen höheren Tears auch noch was zu machen, wie holt sich
denn der Raspberry Pi Daten von der Heizung, also wie gesagt, das hier über Telnet, siehst
du hier, Telnet, TCP, da, Endpoint TCP, TCP Klein, per Telnet und von der Heizung, wie
gesagt, habe ich doch gezeigt, Opto Link, per von der Heizung geht das mit so einem
proprietären Kabel, USB in Raspberry Pi und das steckste vorne hier auf die Heizung drauf,
man könnte auch Temperatur mit Big Data und Deep Neural Network schätzen, das ist wahrscheinlich
genau das Richtige, Blockchain, also ohne Blockchain kommt es bei mir nicht in die Tüte,
außerdem ist es nicht Cloud Native genug, René, was sagst du, könnte man das wenigstens
in der Azure Function auslagern, dass das ganze Serverless läuft, Serverless fast und
dann in die Blockchain über irgendeinen asynchronen Eventbus, vielleicht noch Kafka SS Service
dazwischen oder so, aber Blockchain muss sein, ja ich glaube das sollten wir machen, vielleicht
verifiziert der Twitch Chat an die Transaktion, oh Chat was sagt ihr, Twitch Chat Blockchain,
das wäre nochmal eine gute Idee, die Twitch Chat Blockchain, das wäre wahrscheinlich sogar
mit der passenden Imple, das wäre sogar möglich, Chat Chain, das wäre sogar möglich, da müsste
man nur den Chat irgendwelche komplizierten Aufgaben lösen lassen, aber die Idee ist
wirklich Pongas, macht der Chat so, das reicht aber nicht um Blockchain zu verifizieren,
da müsst ihr irgendwelche Zahlen in ihre Primfaktoren zerlegen, ja genau, genau daran
habe ich auch gerade gedacht, eigentlich müsstet ihr sowas lösen, damit sich das ordentlich
lohnt, Chat Chain wird nur verifiziert, wenn 20 Subs sind, das könnte man natürlich auch
machen, man könnte sicher nicht den Subscriberintervall, in den Subscriberintervall könnte man irgendwas
rein encoden, weil sie immer in so einem 5 Sekunden Takt gucken wie viele Subs, 1 Sub
pro 5 Sekunden ist 1, 0 Sub pro 5 Sekunden ist 0, und dann könnte man irgendwie sowas,
da könnte man, ja das ist eine gute Idee, das sollten wir machen, die Twitch Chat Blockchain,
das ist gut, sag mal aber das ist doch trotzdem doof was ich hier gemacht habe, weil wie setze
ich das denn jetzt, also Temperatur setzen, in dem Fall wäre jetzt relativ easy, also
gehen wir mal davon aus, ich frage was von der Heizung ab, also sagen wir mal hier Temp,
Temp abfragen von Heizung, dann könnte ich danach die Temperatur setzen, ja, keine Ahnung,
12 Grad zum Beispiel, aber dann müsste ich sie hier noch an das Frontend schicken, das
ist eigentlich gar nicht so das Problem, ich frage mich jetzt eher wie ich hier setze,
ich mein ich müsste ja dann quasi hier Heizung setzen und checken ob es geklappt hat, und
dann müsste ich quasi sagen Tage Temp, Temp, das würde funktionieren, das ist aber nicht
Threadsave an der Stelle, ich glaube aber da kann ich darauf verzichten, ich glaube das
muss nicht Threadsave sein, WTF ist Threadsave, Threadsave ist wenn du aus mehreren Threads
auf was zugreifen kannst und es geht dabei nicht kaputt, also zum Beispiel wo das hier
kaputt gehen könnte ist, wenn ich jetzt im Hintergrund permanent von der Heizung abfrage,
was es für eine Temperatur hat und ich setze das hier unten, stell dir vor, wir machen
einfach mal ein Beispiel, wir machen einfach mal ein Beispiel, also stell dir vor ich mache
hier unten einen neuen Thread auf, der parallel zum restlichen Programm läuft und der macht
nichts anderes als while true in der Endlosschleife setzt er hier irgendwelche Werte von der aktuellen
Temperatur der Heizung, so und parallel würde ich hier oben bei jedem Klick aufs Webinterface
die Temperatur setzen, jetzt kann es ja sein, dass sich das ins Gehege kommt, weil es parallel,
hier wird parallel Sachen reingeschrieben, also quasi in diesem Thread unabhängig hier
von und je nachdem was man da macht, so eine variablen Zuweisung ist in der Regel relativ
safe, da passiert erstmal nichts, aber da kann es zu Problemen kommen, weil ja quasi
zwei, es sind ja keine Prozesse, weil zwei Threads parallel schreibend auf den gleichen
Inhalt zugreifen, das führt in der Regel immer zu Problemen, was keine Probleme macht,
also man kann eigentlich normalerweise sagen, wenn du nur liest, also wenn du nur liest
aus der Variable aus dem Speicher, dann kannst du das mit so vielen Threads wie du willst
machen, das ist eigentlich kein Problem, also hast du irgendeine Liste mit Zahlen und liest
da aus verschiedenen Threads, das war überhaupt kein Problem, was meistens auch kein Problem
ist, sind mehrere Threads lesen, ein Thread schreiben, das geht meistens, aber auch da
muss man schon ein bisschen gucken, das ist aber meistens relativ easy zu lösen, was
richtig abfuck wird ist, wenn potenziell mehrere Threads schreiben und mehrere Threads lesen
können.
Gibt es eine Kurzfassung, was gebaut wird, ja, ich kann, dass ich meine Heizung anstellen
kann über Home Assistant, ich habe hier einen Thermostat, wo ich Zeug einstellen kann, an
ausschalten und ich habe die Möglichkeit, dass, oh warte mal, ich glaube meine Katze
wird leiden, exquisite, Katze am Start.
Genau, also wir sind jetzt schon ein bisschen weiter als letztes Jahr, wo ich nur mein Heizungs-Dashboard
hatte, ich gehe mal kurz zurück, also letztes Jahr hatte ich ja nur mein Heizungs-Dashboard,
wir sind jetzt schon ein bisschen advanceder, wir haben jetzt die Heizung integriert in
Home Assistant, Raspberry Pi und an der Heizung dran, ich kann hier Sachen einstellen, da
sie an die Heizung übertragen, aktuell funktioniert das hier auf Home Assistant Seite schon ganz
gut, die Kommunikation mit der Heizung funktioniert aber noch nicht richtig und der umgedrehte
Weg, wenn man jemand an der Heizung was setzt oder die Heizung neue Infos hat, zum Beispiel,
dass sich die aktuelle Temperatur geändert hat, das Weitergeben zum Webinterface funktioniert
auch noch nicht.
Das müsste man noch machen, aber ich glaube man hat es jetzt verstanden, was ich mit Multi-Threaded
beziehungsweise Thread-Safe meine, oder, also immer wenn du hier aus mehreren Threads auf
die gleiche Stelle schreiben zugreifst, gibt das Probleme, so was hier in die Richtung
könnte man machen, so Chat, exzellent, ich habe heute eigentlich noch Zeit, aber wisst
ihr was, ich kann mich nicht mehr konzentrieren, wir haben heute zwar nicht super krass Progress
gemacht, aber ein bisschen wenigstens, ein bisschen so Low-Percent-Progress, Michael 50
Billionen ist auch mal wieder am Start, huge, dazu kann ich bloß sagen, lange nicht mehr
gesehen, es gibt Leute, die kennt man einfach schon im Chat, was ich auch immer echt beeindruckend
finde, wenn ich auf YouTube gucke, wenn ich auf YouTube gucke und dadurch die Kommentare
scrolle und sehe, da ist immer mal das aktuelle Video, und sehe, dass da Leute dabei sind,
also immer wenn ich durchscrolle sehe ich manchmal Namen, ja ey, hier ist auch, okay
da ist was dran, aber hey, ich sage das nicht einfach so, das führt dazu, dass ich ausgeglichener
bin, ich habe mich letztens über die Bahn aufgeregt, nicht gerade sonderlich freundlich,
ja, ja und das ist lustig hier, wenn ich hier durchscrolle, sehe ich immer wieder Leute,
ja ihn kenne ich auch direkt vom Namen zum Beispiel, auch wenn er früher glaube ich
leicht anders hieß, dass man, dass man Leute einfach erkennt, das ist, das ist nice, nice
zu, wieder ist das Wetter morgen, muss ich erfrieren, wenn ich die Heizung nicht einschalten
kann, Wetter, Samstag, Moment, das stimmt glaube ich nicht, morgen, morgen scheint die
Sonne, Vormittag, oder gehe ich ne Runde, gehe ich ne Runde wandern hier so, 10 bis
12, dann ist das Wetter kacke, wird das denn morgen so, ja bis 13 Uhr gehts, nice, Fock,
ja mach ich, so, was die Weedfrage ignoriert, doch, habe ich doch vorhin sogar schon vorgelesen,
es war doch der Skurr, Skurr Typ, ähm, tja, also wir haben ein bisschen Procrust gemacht,
weiß es nicht ob ich, ich frag mich immer noch was mit YouTube los ist, warum ich keine
gescheite Empfehlung mehr bekomme, irgendwie als hätte ich, als hätte ich mein Profil
gelöscht, hab ich aber nicht, weiß nicht wo sind es, Broken, Broken AF, was ist denn
vielleicht muss ich so, oh, oi oi oi, Chrome Patches sind am Start, bin ausgeloggt, das
ist normal, ich bin immer ausgeloggt, aber trotzdem lernt YouTube ja mit der Zeit was
man gucken will, Huge Procrust, ja siehst du hier habe ich das ja noch nie aufgehabt
drauf, da ist es genauso random, so und normalerweise habe ich hier, WTF, normalerweise kriege ich
hier ordentliche Empfehlungen, aber das hat sich irgendwie, hat sich irgendwie resettet,
ja, ich weiß auch nicht, naja, ok Leute, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, ich mach mich
jetzt vom Acker, bis dann, C U.